watching that first are you queuing to
the are you doing the are you really
looking
talk ridiculous oh is it is phenomen
he's hanging off a plane what's next
going to hang off a space shuttle it's
so
ridiculous you are so freaking
predictable look at you picking Leonard
DiCaprio for a comic book movie it's
going to I I use facts in arguments
that's predictable
use
from screen junkie studios in the Heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
movie fights now your host Andy signor
greetings screen junkies for the Epic
return of Ms versus Roa I'm so happy to
be here I'm your host and judge Andy
signor and you guys I can't believe this
is finally happening these two got so
intense they took a break for a while
then they did some showns other things
but they are finally back here for the
Battle of all B battles to end this epic
Trilogy that started here on movie
fights I'm so happy to do it and to do
this right we did we're doing this so
big we have an audience here let's cut
to our fan crowd yeah what's up
guys guys I'm are you guys excited we
get to see man Roa let's see who who's
voting for
mans oh who's voting for
Roa H okay good oh wow Dan Dan now you
there's some mans for those that don't
know on the scho down Roa took the belt
from you he did he didn't take it he won
it he won it fair sir he won it fair and
square so uh but so you're rooting for
mans today I well technically I have to
be impartial and I will I will conduct
my duties impartially but personally
yes well I'm excited to have it we have
some amazing fights today including best
Ridley Scott movie what Spielberg's most
overrated movie and of course The
Ultimate Showdown Star Wars versus Star
Trek there are so many rounds we're
doing six today that's right we're gonna
because this is going to be one-on-one
these guys talk so much I didn't want a
third wheel in here I don't want a third
wheel messing this up I want to hear
their both arguments I want to see who's
really going to win this so let's bring
him out first up he is mini movie critic
for Access Hollywood and lover of La La
Land ladies and gentlemen Scott
M
yeah
[Applause]
yeah hello Scott movie Man welcome
what's just a minute just a minute hang
on hang
on oh it's a strip show
oh Superman is here here we go here we
go ready I'm ready I'm so happy thank
you for doing this Scott I I've been
waiting for this you know that movie
There Will Be Blood this is the sequel
I'm going to drink his milkshake I'm
going to drink it up it's going to get
ugly all right well you're going to have
to get through this milkshake for sure
second up you've seen him on the ciles
and super animation game time it's the
current scho down trivia Champion it's
the outlaw John
[Music]
Ro J is here he's sitting right next to
me oh the fans are giving you crap of
it you're on my world now you're in my
world now belt that's right look
belt come on now give me the belt come
on give it to me
oh look can I see this belt uh all right
let's see let's see how so they really
just took a they just took a WWF belt
and put a little plaque on it Dan you
see how lazy that was don't be
bash you see how our isn't personally
engraved with our faces in it yeah yeah
no I love I love to give Christian crap
that's it's really heavy this is legit
are those real rubies to the carrot
there we
go John I'm so happy to have you thank
you thank you for being here thank for
doing this we're back thank you we are
back yeah and I mean John let's make it
happen I mean it's it's going to get
ugly there a mop did you guys bring a
mop lety host need a mop to clean up the
blood this is not this is not movie
friends it's not movie Buddies you said
this already it's movie fights set it on
camera for the record let them belt all
right now guys first off before it gets
hit bloody I just want to thank you both
cuz you were both wonderful people I
know this I know it's going to get hot
and heavy so I'm doing this now just
want a nice clean
fight good CLE but I want to make it
clear like I because I know you and I
have some had some crap Roo like I love
you both respect you both tremendously
this is going to be a very tough one for
me to to judge I'm going to do my best
we do have some I know they're they're
they be unfair towards man so I'll take
them by by Grand assault but I'm going
to treat this very seriously and I hope
you guys will too I know you will uh but
first before we begin thank you both for
bringing this back to where it all
started and doing this again it started
here it's going to be a lot of fun it
started here and and I'm so glad you got
to continue it elsewhere and do it more
and the fans love it I love it so let's
get to this WOW before we do I want to
introduce our our champ Mr Dan mer yeah
Dan he's still our champ fact Checker
today you ready D I'm ready uh there's
there's a lot going on in this fight
Andy yes does everybody know what's what
what what is happening there is a lot to
go down this fight I want to I know how
well they know this but this is March
Mania here on screen junkies wow this is
the beginning of several good fights in
fact we have a promo to show it why
don't we do that firsto check out this
promo for the March what you're what
you're going to get here for
[Music]
March the Roa man Feud started right
here he is going to Ru the
[Music]
day the belt is going to be on the
line let's get the battle begun some of
our best fighters of all time you will
not want to miss
this you want we are thr Down The
Gauntlet this month on movie fights some
amazing stuff coming soon uh and there
will be some belt uh belt preliminary
championship belt battles now let me
explain this because this battle
actually is going to affect that is it
how so the winner of this fight as if
there couldn't be any more Stakes yeah
gets a seat in the semifinal battle for
the
belt you will get a fast track to the
semifinals to determine out of those
that three people will fight in that
battle the winner of that battle will go
one-on-one against our champ for the
belt that's amazing I'm really looking
forward to even at one and five I get a
shot at this semi well look I won't say
that this didn't help you get there
that's right but we Dan and I both
agreed we wanted to see you win one more
to get there so that's why we're doing
this so the winner of this will get into
the semi-final round then in in March
Champ's Choice Dan is going to choose
three Fighters right Dan let's not
announce the you were going to pick
three fighters to who are going to get
the second seat correct I have selected
three Fighters three worthy opponents
three people that I think all of them
are worthy challenging me for the belt
I've selected three of them those three
will face off the winner of that fight
will face the winner of this fight and
the third scene in that fight will be a
viewer's choice where you guys were
clearing a bunch of schedules to make
sure they're all willing anyone on that
list will be down to do this you will
pick three Fighters that earned have
aside from the people will will have
chosen who get the third seat those
three people will fight we have some
epic stuff is the bottom line plus Paul
sheer Kamal this is Disney fight you
guys have been man and we're finally
doing Collider Allstar last fighter
standing it's going to be epic all your
cler favorites are going to come over
and do it so March Mania is in full
effect are you guys
excited longt sorry but this is this is
a big month for us and you guys are the
the starring attraction you're kicking
us off I assume I don't need to remind
you how the show Works you're all good
to go we good we are good we know we
know it we know this right that's
something we agree on we know this BR
what are you doing right now stop this
fight out stop out kill you
Let Them Fight oh let's get it on let's
do this we're about to do round one but
before we do I want to thank our fans
over there real quick I forgot to do it
can we get a quick shot of our fans are
they Max do you have a oh Max is hey we
see some of them Max is going to adjust
there we go uh I want to thank Jake and
Brie right you guys are there from the
front Jake and Bri hello and we have
Antonio and Matthew hey guys and we have
Simone guys you're all here I'm happy
you can be here I'm going to need your
help throughout this fight so make sure
you're listening to the arguments uh and
have fun today okay I got two questions
you have a mic I think Simone you have
the mic yeah you can you have questions
you have a wand I won't you have a wand
I what do you have a wand you're
Hufflepuff do you have a wand oh no I
don't I'm sorry you haven't been fitted
yet I'm sorry come find me in Harry
Potter land I work as a wand keeper I
will fit you with your one Simone I okay
I'll I'll come and tell that fool to get
the United States of America off his ass
that's my flag I served eight years in
this country not for some pot smoking
kid to wear my American flag on his ass
hey hey I'm wearing this so hopefully I
can uh have the rock Walk in in the
maras right now I got my full Nick M
suit
Nick get that beard going son get that
beard I don't think the Rocks Maring
anybody else anytime soon right I think
we covered that all right here we go
round one this one comes in off Twitter
from London simples uh and this is a big
one I hear the booth mic or there's a
mic yeah just kill that uh r one this
comes in from London simples uh and the
question is what is we heard this cuz
the alien Covenant trailer came out so
we thought what is the best Ridley Scott
movie Scott you're up first I have a
feeling I know what you're gonna say
what is it well I'm going to say bla
Runner not just because it is Ridley
Scott's best movie but it is my favorite
movie of all time number one on the
movie man's best of list topping Close
Encounters Back to the Future wrath or
Khan Empire Strikes Back it is
absolutely brilliant in every sense of
the word it is a movie that could have
been shot today it looks like it could
have been shot today the production
values of this movie there's there's so
much subtext to this film that that you
have to see it over and over again and
you get something new about it every
time you see it you have the production
design marrying the east of and the West
creating what is now known as cyberpunk
you have the influence of this film that
that this movie influenced the likes of
Strange Days The Matrix Minority Report
Children of Men you have every bit of
poetic dialogue especially that tears
and Rain moment at the very end and you
have the question the question proposed
although not overtly what does it mean
to be human so the replicants have a
shelf life of four years and they are
Androids does it mean they are not human
and you have the overall question that
we are still asking to this day although
we already know or maybe we don't
because the sequel is coming out in
October ber Blade Runner
2049 is or was Rick Deckard played by
Harrison Ford a replicant this is a
movie that has been that has been
reedited over the years because Ridley
Scott wanted to get it right so clearly
he cares about it the movie cost about
30 27 or 31 million to make it made half
that at the box office yeah was a
failure box it was a bomb it was a bomb
it came out the same month as Wrath of
KH Poltergeist ET the Extraterrestrial
and and the thing the greatest month
ever for science fiction was June of
1982 closing argument is oh he's already
giving his closing it is the best it is
simply the best for all well I hope
he'll hear more but let's see what
John's picking okay my this a great
choice Blade Runner I absolutely love
Blade Runner as well uh but I went with
alien 1979's alien we' covered it on the
ciles uh which is one of my podcasts
that I do it is an absolutely fantastic
film a groundbreaking film 1979 you have
a female protagonist a very powerful
strong female protagonist in sour
Weaver's character of Ripley we see what
we have we've seen this movie influence
numerous films going forward you
mentioned films there's so much even as
recently as life likes look life looks
very similar to alien what is coming out
with Jake Gyllenhaal and Rebecca
Ferguson what's so amazing about this is
the pacing of this film is so perfectly
made for the 70s and ' 80s it works it
cross came out 79 crosses both decades
Works effectively in both decades and as
Scott just said about Blade Runner you
could absolutely shoot alien out and it
would still 100% work the actors the act
the actors in the film the storyline
what happens and how each of these
actors is or killed throughout the movie
works so effectively and it establishes
this Legacy that we still see now today
with alien Covenant coming out we see it
in comic books we see it in book form we
see multiple films we see offshoots we
see alien fighting Predators now there's
so much about this film that launched a
franchise launched a mythology launched
a universe so much so the Ridley Scott
did did amazing work with this initial
start to this franchise and keeps coming
back to it and improving it and you can
go back and forth on Prometheus all you
want but there are parts of it that
really help the legacy of the film all
right also it also tackles the Android
issue that you spoke about already with
the Android versus human that whole
thing from the beginning what was Ash
evil or bad can they have a feelings can
they have emotions can we see him go
through a whole process of what that
means so and it tackled misogyny very
very powerfully for a time when women
were about finding their strength in all
forms of media in the 70s all right
strong openings on why both your films
are great I think no one's going to den
KN that they aren't a great film why is
yours the best Ridley Scott movie go
ahead okay uh moving moving on now
listen this is a tough argument because
alien and bla Runner are are two of his
best movies I mean Gladiator Thum Louise
are great but I mean these are the two
his first two like Breakthrough films
alen 79 and Blade Runner 82 but one
thing I forgot to mention about Blade
Runner is the score vanelis score score
is one of the greatest musical scores of
all time Jerry Goldsmith score for alien
also very good fantas but vanal is
better and again alien all the things
you said about alien I agree
wholeheartedly with but I feel like
Blade Runner just goes to another level
yes aliens spawned all these sequels and
with the exception of aliens directed by
James Cameron came out in 1986 I just
feel like nothing matched the Brilliance
of the first alien it inspired a lot
inspired a lot of of sequels Blade
Runner did more than inspired sequels it
inspired everything it didn't Inspire
any sequels until just now well that's
it took almost 40 years to get a sequel
I mean what are we talking about didn't
need to of course didn't answer the
question of
or was he a replicant or was he a human
the re didn't have any because nobody
went to see it still asking that
question because when the when the
director's cut came out in 1982 or 19
late 1991 uh it was established because
they added like a Little Dream sequence
of unicorn now now if he had the dream
sequence how the Gaff knew at the end to
build the little origami unicorn how did
he know they was dreaming about a
unicorn unless it was on his file
because he was a replicant but still it
was never officially established and
even when the when the Final Cut came
out in 2007 and I literally asked Ridley
Scott is he a replicant and he said what
do you think and I said yes and I told
him why because of the answer I just
gave you and he said you're right he's a
replicant but people still like to talk
about it well he says that but then he
changed it in different interviews so
you don't know which it depends on who's
asking and what maybe we'll find out in
the sequel which is by the way directed
by Den Vu who is like the greatest one
of the greatest directors today batting
a thousand a rival sakario prisoners
enemy he is anybody is going to direct a
sequel to Blade Runner it's got to be
the I'm looking forward to it but my
issues with Blade Runner terrible
voiceover one of the worst uses of
Harrison Ford ever you can't contradict
that he can redo the film five separate
times to me I'm like if it's a great
film why are you redoing it five
separate times why you keep re-editing
it what's the problem here you know
alien he only added a couple of scenes
for the special edition that's it
because it's such a masterpiece already
it's a masterpiece of horror it's a
masterpiece of sci-fi it crosses all
those genres completely and was
absolutely something new right now this
idea of unicorns how obvious can you be
does that mean you're you're a separate
you know you're a magical creature
you're like all of it was hitting you
over the head there was no Nuance to
that
way The Last Unicorn was like was like a
year later we' seen it already
there was nothing subtle about him doing
origami and seeing that thinging in slow
motion there's nothing subtle going on
there like the trar logo so wrong why do
I care people why do I care about Sam
Deckard he kills replicants by the end
of the movie Whatever whatever the end
of the movie by the end of the movie I
care for the replicants more than
Deckard I care for the replicants
because he's killing these slaves that
humans have created and but the whole
point is but why would you take a lead
and undercut your lead but you're
undercutting your lead you don't do that
Al squeezes the life out of Terell I
mean that is a Mur when he squeezes that
crushes his skull putting his there is
nothing in Blade Runner there's nothing
in Blade Runner that Rivals HR giger's
work in Alien nothing not a [__]
thing you know that there is nothing
anywhere close because Scott Scott went
to Scott went to college for design
right that's what he used for both the
so all that's there in both no time out
here and then HR Giger comes in and has
this amazing
work that has influenced so many people
through the years okay wait a second
wait a second you talk about okay so so
R Scott he didn't have to go back he
just did a couple of things to alien
because it was already perfect I won't
argue against that but what I will will
argue for is that yes he saw that the
voice over bla Runner was so far ahead
of its time that the studio Warner
Brothers got nervous and they insisted
that they he used the the voice over
with Harris for which was so bad that
when the director's cut came out he took
it out he cared enough about this movie
that he wanted to get it right but that
wasn't the only change made he made
three separate ver hang on just a minute
now now he he made another version he
made his final cut in 2007 because again
he loved this movie so much it was so
far ahead of its time he ran out of
money the movie bombed but he loved it
so much he kept going back to it because
it was his baby he even said in
interviews that it was his personal
favorite of his movies no that's not
what he said he said that in another
interview he said alien was his favorite
movie so it all depends on when you
interview really SC it what he's going
to say he he also said Martian was one
of the favorite movies he's ever
directed so there's no point to be made
there it's all a matter of who when he's
being interviewed and what film he's
promoting as a good director should my
interview for a Hollywood in
2007 Runner was his favorite movie and
Dan I don't know if he can find it
online I don't know if it's online it
should be I'm sure there are multiple
instances of really Scot saying he likes
C Dan sure is on it with these kind of
and here's another thing about it there
there's nothing that got spawned from
Blade Runner nothing there's no extra
there's no spin-offs there's no comic
books there's no other and that's the
thing it it it alien hit such a nerve in
the pop culture that it is still
permeating Generations later people in
and influen so many movies in I would
say a rival then the reason vuv comes
back to do Blade Runner is because of
what happens with with alien in you see
an arrival arrival there are there are
influences from really Scotts alien in
arrival the pacing the way the aliens
are done the fear the dread the drama
all of that is allal I agree with all
that now alien was a hit right yes alien
was a hit BL Runner was not right now
neither was Star Trek the motion picture
but they still made a second one now now
Star Trek the motion picture made enough
money it made enough money barely enough
money but then why I keep coming back
and redoing it it's because it has a
second life on VHS and on beta there
wasn't enough to make a SE the point
that I'm making Mis is this alien was a
hit alien was a hit yes it was and it
was fine like he only had to make
because it's a masterpiece wait a minute
some of the greatest movies of all time
are movies that got mixed reviews movies
that did not do well at the Box office
upon their initial release but it took a
very long time for people to wrap their
heads wait hang on around Citizen Kane
around wonderful life around
200 and around Blade Runner because it
was there was so much to it that you
need to see it a few times you need to
look back on it with perspective and
you're saying that oh well it didn't
have any sequels again all the movies
that I mentioned before the movies that
it inspired it created a whole sort of
sub genre unto itself in science fiction
the post-apocalyptic future the
cyberpunk the the conest boy and his dog
had come out before that was
post-apocalyptic future all through the
70s were post-apocalyptic movies so
Blade Runner didn't come out and make
some post-apocalyptic new stylized
vision of the dystopian future that is
what this movie created the cyberpunk
depiction of the future the marrying of
the East and the West it was the future
and the past the futuristic uh you know
with the with the uh The Spinners
fil the
the you know the rain and the night and
all that exactly but all of that is
there in Alien as well it is also posted
post is in the future it's got all the
it's got all the rain it's got all that
Noir stuff going on plus it got it has
horror plus it has drama plus it has all
it has a Sci-Fi vibe to it that's the
thing about alien alien crosses multiple
genres that's why it's a masterpiece
blade bu is a fantastic sci-fi film it's
a great sci-fi film but it's not a
horror film it's not it's not any kind
it's it's not it's not a dramat not
necessarily a dramatic film it's a
sci-fi
film a lot more big pictures Blade
Runner asks big big bigger questions it
is a much bigger picture kind of movie
Alien works as a horror film it works as
a science fiction film it is it is
suspenseful and intense and all that
stuff and Sigourney Weaver was a
Trailblazer as a strong female character
who who had a much more prominent impact
in that role with the follow-up film but
we're not talking about aliens we're
talking about alien uh that's it weing
now in closing in closing I mean you
have this movie that was so great that
there's so much to it that people that
the times are still catching up to Blade
Runner people are still getting more out
of it books have been written about it
classes have been taught people have
been writing their thesises around the
ideals the look The feel the dialogue of
bla Runner I mean uh tears in rain I'm
not in the business I am the business
wake up time to die every bit of that
dialogue is brilliant and quotable it
just transcends the genre final marks
with alien you have a female protagonist
right all the protagonists all the
female characters in blad are all
bouncing off men this is what is so
fantastic about alien it blazes the
trail initially you think it's Tom
scared who's going to lead the movie Tom
scared gets pass it to the wall then out
of nowhere sour Weaver comes in and she
becomes the lead she is the character
that carries that franchise in the first
movie don't give me the second movie The
First movie too she carries it there
because she's a stickler she's a
character we had seen before done by men
before and they become dead they get
killed and whatever CU they're the ones
that are sticks in the mud but what
she's doing is right she's fighting
against this misogyny within the whole
film and it is trailblazing in that way
then you add HR giger's uh amazing
design of the alien amazing design of
this entire uh film then you add the
Noir aspects of it all then you add the
horror aspects of it all then you you
add the Fantastic script and you add the
fact that it sees the future before we
see the future ourselves everything you
see an alien is happening now that's
what's so amazing about this film the
communication space talking through
space communicating with back how to do
uh pickups all these kinds of things are
happening all through this is what
they're working on now in NASA all this
stuff is influenced Star Trek did that
no and
with Dan Dan good start all right good
warmup here Dan anything you like to add
to clean up eyes so much to go through
Scott was completely right on this June
1982 I didn't even know that Rath Theon
and Poltergeist released the same week
the next week was ET two weeks later
blade runner in the thing so five
Classics in one month that's pretty
crazy am that's amazing Blade Runner had
a reported $28 million production budget
gross 275 on its initial release so not
a money maker uh Blade Runner had of
course the theatrical cut it had a cut
that was released internationally the
director's cut mat was in 1992 and then
the Final Cut and I I've been looking
for rid got quotes on favorite movies
that he liked the one that I could find
was he was asked what his favorite
Sci-Fi movies were he listed 2001 Star
Wars and then in this order alien and
Blade Runner but that's the only quote
you know he may have other options
that's the that's what I could find in
the time that I have well well well we
also have a poll that I will give you
the results of uh after you make your
ring tough call this is aough call Great
films but there there did there was a
winner and it came down to the final
thoughtss but right before your
closings I
think John yeah gave me a little bit
more as to how it spurred it spawned uh
uh different genres and how it uh
spawned more than I think uh we got out
of Blade Runner um coupled with all the
amazing things you've been listing I
think were also in were both in both
films there was a lot of things
canceling out but those things stuck to
me more the fact that it crossed
multiple genres spawn so much still
permeant today uh and then also your
argument at the voice over and Blade
Runner was a little bit of a knock
because which version of the film do you
there that's that's we don't have that
against St so John gets the first point
oh take off those American pants right
now let's go I don't want to see his
junk Halo he's probably got an American
speedo on underneath uh Andy Twitter
agrees with you right now by 65 to 35
margin the home crowd voting for alien
is the best
SC movieo you'll all you'll all learn
you will all learn all right well we got
six rounds today it's going to be a long
show let's do it uh round two this one
comes in from Nate Bridgeman the
question is what is Step Spielberg's
most overrated movie uh I you got to
pick a movie that some people really
like yeah uh what is he can't pick the
terminal is
all I call it the ter the terrible what
I can't believe he did that movie it's
like a yeah weird Burger King airport
Burger King ad um here we go uh it's
your turn now John what is Spielberg's
most overrated movie well here we go as
a serviceman of eight years I will say
in my opinion Saving Private Ryan is one
of the most overrated films ever when
you get past the first 25 minutes which
is stupendous amazing I remember getting
emotional three times I just got it out
of basic training when I saw that movie
it was so fantastic the first 25 minutes
or 20 minutes one of the most amazing
battle SE quences I've ever seen that I
have not seen anything since until
hacksaw Ridge which was amazing but
after that it becomes boring as hell and
it goes through these things you you're
introduced to these actors and these
characters that are caricatures of
themselves I'm the New York guy I'm the
start talking guy I'm the guy that's the
best friend but all this kind of stuff
then you get the doctor who's crying for
his mama you know all this kind of stuff
that's all characters that we'd seen
caricatures that we'd seen already in
previous World War 2 films or previous
war films then Damon doesn't even want
to go with them when they finally find
him so it makes all those deaths
irrelevant both before and after
including Tom hanks's death all right
and the swerve at the end where we we
just toose we think it's Tom Hanks and
it's actually Matt Damon at the end what
a terrible swerve and the guy turns
around looks at his ly white beautiful
happy beautiful family and goes was I
good tell me I was a good man what what
is wrong with you of course you're a
good man look at this beautiful family
look they're amazed they' come with you
to the cemetery to celebrate your
service this country it was ridiculous
all right the whole thing about the
mission is ridiculous and it was a PR
stunt by the military to save face why
are they go why is Ryan's life worth
more than any of those people in that
platoon including Tom heck Tom seore
Edward Burns Giovanni rabi um uh Vin
Diesel all those people Adam Goldberg is
that his name Adam Goldberg all those
people in that in that platoon their
lives are worth just as much just CU
their brothers didn't die in World War
II doesn't make their lives any less and
so to me that's so so ridiculous it's
also slow paced it takes forever to get
there and it's essentially the Disney
version of Apocalypse Now and that's not
what war is J war is the first 25
minutes are you [__] kidding me the
version of Apocalypse Now it that is the
craziest after you get the first 25
minutes batshit craziest thing I've
heard since it
isn't is the most B craziest heard no
there's been a mistake uh wow is it Mye
turn can I something in there what is
your pick okay my pick is minority
reports because Minority Report is a
technically
proficient wait a minute you have your
five hours talk you had your five hours
to to stand up on your soapbox mister so
here's mine and I'm only going to take
five
seconds that would be a miracle
report good one yes minor report you
know it is a technically proficient like
Blade Runner based on a story by Philip
K dick and very much inspired by uh
Blade Runner in terms of its
post-apocalyptic depiction of the future
but M marrying uh overcrowding with
technological achievements but when it
comes down to it Minority Report is
extremely cold convoluted confusing
overwritten overexplained and completely
devoid of warmth heart humor or emotion
I did not care about anybody in this
film and I went back and I watched it
again thinking okay you know sometimes
you got to go back and watch a movie a
few times to really appreciate it like
bla Runner and I loved bla Runner I
thought oh my God I love I do love
Spielberg I think he's one of my
favorite director I mean he is one of my
favorite directors but I just didn't I
didn't care about the story I thought it
was thought it was 30 minutes too long
it should have ended when uh when
anderton played by Tom Cruz gets uh sort
of Frozen but it kept going because
Spielberg had to tack on the happy
positive optimistic ending and the movie
suffer because of it that's your
argument that's it nobody over rates
nobody over rates Minority Report my
report is like the top nine or 10 of
Spiel BRS it's like nine or 10 of Spiel
BRS it's not that overrated Private Ryan
is a ballsier choice for me to overrate
that Minority Report no one's going like
oh I got I got to be influenced Minority
Report to make a movie based on Minority
Report it's ridiculous look Min report
is a decent sci-fi film maybe frell's
best work Tom Cruz does a great job Mar
is fantastic with the Eyes First 25
minutes R are the best part
fod follow cut your argument
isting I
got they don't even show minority PS in
the Revival theaters show those first 25
minutes we talked about I've already
conceded the first 25 minutes Inspire
what do you think people said when
hackel Rich came out they said this
movie One those battle sequence were the
best since prying the point I I would I
would ConEd the first 25 minutes that's
why the film sucks because it doesn't
match those first 25 minutes you have to
have but you're going to get Whiplash um
the the the first 25 minutes of the
movie are great and they're ping
fantastic they're fantastic but then you
have to take a deep breath and get into
not for an hour and a what's the story
here then you get into the characters
you get into the heart get into no the
character get into the warm the the
emotion the emotion these guys they were
the grunts they had each other's backs
they sacrificed themselves for one
person and when they get to that person
Matt Damon's character Ryan he was he
want want to do it he wants to serve his
country he wants to stay that was that
was Bal and the sacrifice of everyone
else who had
moral quantry that was in the movie
makes you think sa Private Ryan is far
better far better what makes you think
too this whole idea of preco this whole
idea of see no no it's this whole idea
that we see now that's going on in our
country now this idea of punishing
people before they actually do stuff
just for saying stuff just for thinking
stuff this is happening now at these
minority rallies they just arrested a
woman who had said that her husband and
her her brother got taken by the IC she
they had already looked at her and they
had let her go and they arrested her on
the drive back to her house that's
what's going on The Minority Report laid
that groundwork down and talked about
people committing crimes before they
actually commit the crimes or arresting
them before they actually do something
to try to intimidate them that's what
they were trying to do and that's what
Tom Cruz's that Minority Report was
exposing at the time because the police
state was happening more and more across
the world so what Spielberg wanted to do
was explore that and he did a decent job
of it in Minority Report I don't think
anybody thinks it's a great it's like
the greatest Spielberg film but people
love Private Ryan people argue that
Saving Private Ryan should have won best
picture which I don't I don't I think
Shakespeare love absolutely deserved it
and I will fight that battle I will die
on that Hill every day one of the
biggest upsets of movie in Oscar history
crash anything is one of the biggest
up as much as I love hearing you guys
over talk I do I know some people don't
um you're in for loud at this episode I
think uh let's talk about Minority
Report just I want to make it clear uh
uh John why is that not overrated
because nobody thinks it is one of the
best films the Spielberg has ever made
it's a it's a decent sci-fi film that
he's done there's about n eight or nine
better films that he's made so to me it
doesn't qualify for the question
overrated it has to be pretty popular
film we accepted the answer yeah a lot
of people like the film then why why
don't I think it's overrated I think
it's actually a really really good film
that once again explores this idea of
crime of thought Pro you know it's
thought crime this it's essentially
communism just because you think
something doesn't mean necessarily you
should be arrested for it it asks you to
think about that and explore that within
yourself what is correct can we stop
these people these refugees from coming
over here just cuz we think might be
terrorists that's the whole idea but
that's the thing it's still relevant
today it's still still applies and the
stuff that they're using in the film
very preent we see it now Samsung TVs do
that kind of stuff
Tech it is rated exactly where it's
supposed to be rated Ry now I'm not
talking about the technical proficiency
of the film it is a it the production
design is fantastic I like I know what
the plot is okay I did see the movie a
couple of times but the execution of the
film is is what bother me you strip away
all the bells and whistles and when you
get down to the screenplay because
really it's about him trying to save his
son the play being about to be sexually
abused his son's about to be sexually
abused fting stop happening that this
the dialogue of the film the exposition
of the movie the characters everybody
was explaining the film as it went along
for the dummies out there who couldn't
follow oh my God how many Exposition is
there is in Blade Runner explain the
every but I'm
Exposition BL there's no Exposition oh
my God there's so much Exposition no as
soon as he walks into the office and
talk to his his police chief there's
Exposition every time he start
Exposition that's the setup that's the
setup all maneuver was set up because
they were explaining the movie the
entire time he faces the moral Contry at
the end that you're talking about that
Matt Damon does so does Tom Cruz at the
end do I shoot this guy because I've
been shown that this guy kills my son he
he sexually abuses my son drowns him in
the water and kills my wife at that
moment he has to decide whether he's
going to kill that guy or not whether
he's been manipulated or not and
Samantha Morton I think that's her name
does such an amazing job in that moment
to stop screams scream that's an
amazingly powerful moment the Mora Quan
you say Matt Damon goes to at the N sa
Private Ryan is the exact same moral
quandry that Tom Cruz has to go through
what do I do in that done better but
it's done better over I didn't say it
was done
well against yourself I I would say the
as the scene with in a minor report
better because because it's so boring he
just goes he goes no I want to stay with
my people what about everybody that died
to come get you [__] him I didn't know
him I'm going to stay here with my troop
[__] all that man it's ridiculous it's a
PR stunt by the military there's no
nobility to what they're doing and I say
that as an eight-year veteran of the
army I know the plot I saw the movie a
few times I know the pl got it was a
stunt because they can't have all these
brothers die so of course that was a
stunt they had to sa face part of the
moral Ser the country don't serve the
country that's part Ian but their Liv
shouldn't be less his brother's wait a
minute the first 25 minutes what about
that last battle scene that was pretty
damn good too the movie is bookend up by
two great battle sequences the DJ
sequence is
still the greatest battle SE all time it
is the greatest I don't know why you're
restating the point we've all agreed to
give me new points because well well
okay so as the as they're going along as
they're they're they're making the
journey to find Private Ryan they are
you're finding more about Tom Hanks
character you're finding more about all
these characters there is character
development in Private Ryan that is
missing big time from Minority Report I
wait hang on I cared more about the
characters in Private Ryan it's
bookended by two great battle sequences
and in between you get all this but
quickly why did you care more about the
characters and yours versus Minority
Report because because I wasn't I didn't
I felt like I was discovering the
characters organically versus being told
this is what's happening right this
moments I I discovered the characters
organically so that when you get to the
end and they start getting knocked off
one by one during that last battle scene
like it was it was heartbreaking it was
heartbreaking and that last those last
words from Tom Hanks earn this earn this
earn this two words that sum up the
impact of that movie earn this let me
let me give you a lifetime of
psychological bills Psychiatry bills for
all these people dying for you to earn
this life there so much so that 70 years
later you're still sitting in front of
that Cemetery going did I live a good
life that the film itself inherently is
full of just flaws in this kind of way
minority reports you have Tom Cruz who's
coming in he is like this cocky kid of
course typical Tom Cruz right cocky
stuff but but no no cuz he's he's a
police chief he thinks he thinks he's
he's on charge of stuff he thinks he's
running he's running that thing and then
all of a sudden he gets turned on him
and he has to explore he has to explore
this thing that he has dedicated his
life to he has to go and find the flaws
in it and Max vono turns on him Colin
Ferell who's initially against him also
sees what the problem is and dies in the
process then he has to take the precog
out Samantha Morton and discover her
life which she was stolen from her
mother so you get all this as you go
along so there there's a lot of
character developed confusing it's not
confusing at all I just explained it to
you a [__]
headache thank you JT uh I will say damn
I'm coming to you but I have to say it's
ballsy Roa goes up against the iconic
war movie and man goes up against Tom
Cruz which we know is very hard for him
to do as a lover
uh Dan thoughts well if we're talking
critically you know everyone saying like
oh that one's not overrated that one's
not more overrated if we're talking
critically both movies almost
identically uh regarded by the critics
my report 90% of critics gave it a
thumbs up Saving Private Ryan 92% of
critics of course Saving Private Ryan
got more Awards attention than Minority
Report uh as someone who has Saving
Private Ryan and my top 10 favorite
movies of all time that's all I'm going
to say about this uh but yeah it's an
opinion based round factually was pretty
clean and uh we have the Twitter poll
that I can share once you made your
ruling oh well I'm curious to the fans
back there based on the arguments did
anyone surprise you particular anyone
have a thought um John You Had Me Like
re-evaluate my whole life so I think I
would go with John nice thank you any
other
thoughts any mans fans out
there I was thinking more uh
mans uh he kind of put a lot out there
about
um just with how Minority Report
it's my mind just went blank sorry no
pressure I put the pressure on you all
right well we got one for man one fora
there we go
uh again hate to be in your shoes
brother look I think it came down to the
I got it based on the arguments I'll be
honest I love both of these films so
it's actually really tough um I've seen
them both recently they both do hold up
I think so taking that out of it and
listening to the
arguments uh it was really neck and neck
but then I think Roa really did did give
me a little bit why the characters
aren't caricatures in Minority Report
more uh
it's I got to go with Roa again oh wow
wow based on the arguments it was a
really ballsy and I don't know doesn't
necess agree with it but uh interesting
interesting take so wow you're up by two
Ro unfamiliar feeling
this to lose St all over
again uh all right well here we go this
is oh sorry Dan goad Twitter by a 5941
margin voted for Minority Report uh
personally I would have argued for hook
myself I think that is a lot of nostalg
to I hate hooko I
would M so bad and but enough people
like that that would have
counted P I am not a fan of that film
either all right here we go round three
from gab brues 9 several people
suggested this one this I know is we're
already 45 minutes in sorry in advance
but it is going to be long because I got
to give the time for this fight which is
we've done before but we only got to
argue for like four minutes right Dan
yeah this was done at a a holiday back
way back at the beginning of the show
when we had a very short holiday
schedule this did not get its due and we
thought with these two gentlemen here
this is where we'll get its due all
right here we go guys Star Wars versus
Star Trek let's go let's do this once
and for all let's do it I definitely
want all you listening back there cuz
this is going to be this is going to be
a doozy so let's all listen to these
arguments and man we're back to you I
assume you're picking Star Wars yes how
did you
know I am so the only reason I am here
today is to fight in favor of Star Trek
Star Trek changed my life Star Trek
changed a lot of people's lives I'm
going to give you both advice yes it's
not about what you like like I want to
just make sure I've said that early in
the I don't care what you like this
isn't about what you like well it's
facts I want to know what's the best
Star War cuz I assume you both you like
Star Wars yes John yes I do you grew all
your life grew up like in Star Wars fair
to assume and St man okay great take it
out of the arguments start over go okay
start over go start you I know you are a
treky okay Trekker uh I'm enough of a
treky to know that we like to be called
trekers check all right here's the deal
Star Trek was first September 8th
1966 every episode for the first two
years they they they were Paving their
way you had you had a show that was that
was ahead of its time and predicted a
lot of things about the future you had
stories that were provocative that were
philosophical that were thoughtful that
were
controversial that that uh were
allegories for the times and because a
lot of what they were dealing with in
the late 60s are still prevent now most
of those stories especially from the
original series still hold up Star Trek
was about diversity you know we're
talking about diversity right now
September of 1966 you have a show we
just on the bridge of the Enterprise you
have you have an Asian you have a a
woman from Africa you have a Scottish
guy you have a Vulcan and then the
second season you have a Russian you
know that was diversity more than 50
years ago truck was ahead of its time it
influenced technology communicators our
cell phones view screens our Skyping and
that's just the tip of the iceberg you
had uh uh a show that that that inspired
people to become doctors aerospace
engineers mathematicians astronomers
astronauts Star Trek inspired people to
make the world a better place Star Trek
was where Star Wars wasn't a long time
ago Star Trek was our future Star Trek
Star Wars was in a galaxy far far away
Star Trek was about us we were Star Trek
is about the constant the constant
striving for Perfection and learning
from our mistakes along the way Star
Trek had the better philosophy live long
and prosper it is within you not about
mini Corin or about you know force or
about lightsaber red matter is it about
red matter too well you're going put all
that put all that [__] in you're start
St CRA let's put all the [__] we have we
have more than 72 hours do your star Tre
do your star Tre I 727 hours of Star
Trek there's a lot more of it you have
13 movies a lot more than Star Wars
Captain Kirk is one of the greatest
heroes ever created Star Trek is about
us all right great opening go ahead John
I would okay Star Wars absolutely Star
Wars oh my god wow all right let them
have let's take a look at Star Wars
there we go there is not a person on the
planet that doesn't know what that is
right that's what that's iconic it is
Star Wars is bigger it's it's space soap
opera absolutely but it's also done with
the nuances of character driven plots
the idea of Luke Skywalker who hasn't
felt you say it's about long ago galaxy
far that's not true him standing there
looking at those it says but you're
trying to you're trying to say that Star
Trek is about us but Star Wars isn't and
that's not true there's not a lot
there's not a person in this room who
hasn't had that moment where Luke is
standing there looking at those two sons
on tne wondering what his future is
going to be we all have that moment and
that's what makes it Universal we all
have those issues with those with those
father figures we all have those issues
with the with authority we all have
those issues with good versus evil all
of that is there and that is so relevant
to us still now today this whole idea is
what makes Star Wars so amazing and also
you have a very powerful female
protagonist in Princess Leia yeah Ura
was nice they made her the Comm officer
they didn't give her anything of real
value to do until much much later much
much much later and and that's that's
that's the thing you say it came first
it was only a few years before Star War
Star Wars came out only a few years
years 11 years buddy long it was 10
still only a few years it was
11 either way it's still with the time
frame that it's so ridiculous that it's
it's that's an issue and so to me this
is what Star Wars does really really
well you have this exploration of the
family Dynamic you have expansive worlds
you have creatures that that you can
connect to that you understand what you
don't you don't see terrible makeup on
them these are really well done the
Muppets all that the Yoda is a muppet so
well done so believable you feel his
pain when he dies in Jedi there's
there's moments there Luke fighting his
he's fighting his father there's so much
to go plus the ships the amazing ships
right oh live long oh I'll never join
you I was going to go toi station to
pick power wait wait wait wait I can be
brought back to life on a planet oh
that's real
original star so and the other thing
about Star Wars and this is so amazing
John Williams score go ahead let me see
you argue John Williams score versus any
of the scores any of those star things
right that's what I'm talking
lightsabers are way more cooler than
phaser set to stun how boring is that
[__] Boba Fett if I me anyone in the
star universe that Rivals Boba Fett or
Chewbacca right who Rivals Boba Fett or
Chewbacca Scott who Rivals B question
Boba Fett who Rivals Boba Fett or
chewbaca in Star Trek who Rivals you got
the Klingons you got the Raman you got
the freaking gor who was in one are you
really going to bring the enemies into
this okay wait okay so first of all wait
I'm not done they're the no all the
amazing novels you just said 720 hours
so all the amazing novels and comic
books that have spawned off of Star Wars
that are still coming out today and
still powerful today the overarching
themes of family resisting evil doing
what's right steadying your mind to
handle the world they have better
special effects Advanced film making an
empire is better than any has has a a
better villain than D Vader is a better
villain than any villain Star Trek has
and Empire Strikes Back is a better film
than KH Empire Strikes Back is a better
film than Ron and you know it you know
it it's more layered and complex than
Tre Tre is simple Human Relationships
God Star Wars is more more compelling
story lines you have the Old Republic
you have all this stuff Star Wars Wiki
is visited more than Star Trek Wiki
there just there's just so much about
Star Wars that is so powerful so
relevant still resident the fact that
they just started all over again new
Trilogy right your new Trilogy is
tanking Beyond this crap Into Darkness
was crap the only thing that was good
was the first 2009 reboot that's it
everything else has been crap it's true
Rue one awakens is EXC Beyond was a
throwback they're talking about doing TV
series on Netflix they're talking about
all this stuff is happening they're
already doing a TV series and the show
runner left how would that tell you oh I
don't care who cares first of all who
cares is one of the best showers out
there and he left the show is in by the
way okay you want to talk about
Productions uh uh you know the producer
for The Empire Strikes Back got fired
after that movie because it went over
budget I'm not arguing about about the
fact that hang on hang on the the fact
is okay they fired rodry wait a minute
firstat let's go back to what you said
about Aur okay the fact that she was
just there on the bridge a black woman
on the bridge in a position of power in
1966 wait wait a minute at the height of
the Civil Rights and who was a big fan
wait who was a big fan of Tre Martin
Luther King who was a big fan of Star
Trek Barack Obama he ofar Wars okay wait
just a minute hang on now let's go Jes
is the voice of Darth the [__] does that
mean okay Star Wars okay yeah it's
father son you got some family issues
wait hang on hang on you have yeah you
have your didn't talk for 20 minutes you
have your lightsabers but you also have
phasers phasers are used for defense
they are used for defense you know we'll
defend ourselves if necessary okay wait
a minute you're saying that's Empire
Strikes Back is a great film it's one of
my top five favorite movies of all time
so is the Empire is is the Wrath of Khan
yes the Wrath of Khan uses themes that
are Timeless and from literary Classics
like a tal two cities from Charles
Dickens der Mo dick it but it's you're
using Timeless stories to tell another
Timeless story that is why Wrath of Khan
is the Citizen Cane of Star Trek movies
yeah but the Star Wars Trilogy the Star
Wars Trilogy destroys the Star Trek 2
three and four Trilogy you know that cuz
search of Spock is an uneven film four
is good two is good three is an uneven
film one two and three there are no
uneven situations going on in in Star
Wars you tell me Jedi is up there with
Empire [__] Jedi is bad Jedi a bad
movie is not a bad movie out of your
mind Jedi is overrated Jedi you cannot
go when Vader throws Palpatine down the
shoot that's overrated are you out of
your [__] mind everything is leading
to him doing that everything in the
first two and half two and 3 fil
Empire is a masterpiece frat turn of the
Jedi is garbage frat turn of the Jedi as
soon as you see the Little eok Star Trek
Nemesis Star Trek insurrection Star Trek
everything from Next Generation other
the first Contact is garbage that's the
thing Star Wars has its it has its uh
the prequels you can argue back and
forth but there are plenty of people who
defend the prequels no one's defending
Insurrection no one's defending Nemesis
no one's defending any of those crappy
films after first com are you defending
those tell me tell me a Star Wars M are
you defending those wait with s those
movies again I was Insurrection you
weren't listening
Nemesis I'm going to I'm going to defend
that with this The Phantom Menace attack
of the Clones revenge of the S and I can
tell you there are many many people
millions of people who love the prequels
on numerous podcasts prequels were awful
Joseph scrimshaw being one
of they all have awful awful movies and
great movies The other thing is this
okay yes the Star Trek movies are uneven
there's the the theory and it's been
almost proven that the even numbered
Star Trek movies are better than the
odd-numbered Star Trek movies by when
you break down Star Trek Trilogy Star
Trek's 2 three and four yeah Star Trek 3
is a little weaker than than the wrath
of kind you're saying a little weaker it
is a little weaker because wait wait
hear me out because what first of all
the scene in Star Trek 3 tell me Jedi
sucks to strikes back if three is like
only a three is better than Return of
the Jedi you're out of your mind no way
search they recast CHR Ali you're out of
your mind already there's a continuity
issue of course she
fantastic back back up in Star Trek 2
broken down into its simplest form in
Star Trek 2 Spock died saving the
Enterprise in Star Trek 3 the Enterprise
returned the favor when wait when when
they're look when they're watching the
Enterprise burn up in the atmosphere of
the Genesis planet and Kirk goes what
have I done and McCoy says what you
always do turn death into a fighting
chance to live and wait a minute that
last moment that when Kirk sacrificed
his ship real no no Stakes his son dies
he loses his [__] he puts in his own
career and the career of his colleagues
on the line but then he gets it all back
that's what I mean he gets it all back
in real world like Star Wars people get
it back they come back he gets it back
because he he saved his father saved the
World by going back in time to bring
yeah going back in time the future going
back in time see there's none of those
[__] conventional narratives in Star
Wars ain't nobody going back in time in
Star Wars you deal with what's happening
right in front of you and you deal with
the consequences and the rication enough
to go back to realiz that there was an
environmental issue writ WR
a back environmental issue in the 20th
century that say oh my God there's no
whales it was an allegory it was a it
was a it was an environmentally
conscious movie what Star Wars movie is
provocative and serves an as an allegory
for our times like this don't talk about
the family [__] you know don't talk
about I'm going to give you all the
arguments you're going to go no don't
talk about that what the [__] you
talking course I can talk about that
that's exactly what the whole point of
it is you know what kind of people like
Star Trek smart people you know what
kind people like Star Wars smart and
Incredibly creative people who don't use
who don't use stupid conventions in
order to solve their problems hey you
know what we're going to we're going to
shoot we're going to use Genesis machine
we're going to use a Genesis machine to
reth everybody matter matter everybody
idolizes what did Darth Vader do he
[__] kills people he Str people are
idolizing so did KH people love con so
do the clons people love the Klingons so
the Borg people love the Borg what the
[__] you talking about this is what I'm
telling you Darth Vader gets redeemed
that's the point that there's a chance
for all of us all this [__] you talk
about with Star Trek with the whole live
long and prosper and all this stuff
there's a chance for Redemption for all
of us when you see that
Invader does that Luke sacrifices
himself infinite diversity infinite
comination at end of the trilogy
sacrifices himself he does not fight
back cuz he wants his father to fight
Palpatine once and for all he wants to
reclaim his father who he believes is
Anakin and there's good in Anakin and in
that moment he takes all the blasts from
the emperor because he knows he's either
going to die or his father's going to
fight back once and for all and be his
dad and that moment is so incredibly
powerful and I'm going to tell you that
influenced a lot of people in their
relationships I'm sure watching that
film going back and seeing that CU not
all of us have the best relationships
with our dad we come back so that's
about us Star Wars is about us Star Trek
what I'm telling Star Trek is about us
no you have a philandering guy who walks
around who walks goes planet to planet
sleeping with all the women me a break
terrible acting cheesy acting L Nemo is
the only saving grace of Star Trek the
only saving grace Star Trek you have a
terrible Russian accent from per it's
the reason that people became and people
joined the military to be a captain of
of of of the aircraft by that logic then
Top Gun is one of the greatest films
ever made while Star Trek came first I
need closings here because I'm I'm
trying to listen to it
all uh respect Andy respect uh I I I
need to know we all know why these films
are great everyone look both of these
franchises are great obviously people
have their favorite why overall in the
world it's of everything give me more
than you don't repeat yourself but just
why is Star Trek better than Star Wars
mans and why is Star Wars better than
Star Trek John okay you mean closing
arguments just help me hammer at home
broadly let's go listen I I said all the
reasons at the top of my argument I I
mean I I he said don't repeat yourself
so don't repeat I'm going to I'm just
going to defer to to the beginning of
this piece then I said everything at the
top about about the the the stories and
on top of all the provocative thoughtful
philosophical stories and the fully
realized characters Star Trek was about
friendship Kirk spach and McCoy
constantly constantly sacrificed
everything for each other on a repeated
basis Star Trek was an action adventure
in addition to being provocative
entertainment
why
andies because we are always learning
about ourselves and we that will always
Inspire Star Trek to be made okay John
now when everything you just said that's
in Star Trek is also in Star Wars but in
real life ways people die people don't
people have to fight back they have to
fight out of their situation they have
to understand who they are they have to
discover these kinds of things they have
to go on their hero's journey that's
what makes Star Wars so relatable so
Universal to everyone who watches it
that's why they love it that's why they
keep coming back do multi they do video
games that are so much better they do
the Old Republic all these things that
are there within the Star Wars universe
that explore different stories you can't
tell me JY erso losing her father in
Rogue one is not an incredibly powerful
moment these are real things that are
happening people that's what I'm trying
to tell you Star Trek takes the easy way
out they can go back in time they can
use red matter they can uh shoot eject a
person who's dead onto a planet that
brings him back to life there are no
Stakes he eats the Apple cuz he shaded
on the Kobayashi Maru test there are no
Stakes even Spock dying is no stake yes
his son dies but that's the only time he
has any kind of stake and loss well in
Star Wars you have to lose and then go
forward and find a way out and still
stuff isn't fixed we see that Force
awakens there's something going on with
Luke Luke's at his end he's been cut off
he's there un bearded on the mountain
There's real consequences that's real
life see Star Wars is about us Star Trek
is about this idea that we could be
something Star Wars is actually what we
really are and that's what's amazing
about Star Wars and that's why it's more
Universal that's why there's so many
books about it comic books and all media
and sucessful fantastic media no one
talks about the Star Trek books at
all [__] Dan and the gallery over there
yeah uh man that was something um just
to delve into this a little bit Gary CTS
the original producer of the first two
Star Wars movies uh said he was fired he
claims that he left due to his
dissatisfaction with George Lucas
increased focused on marketing and toy
sales these are his words now that could
be some dispute but that that's his side
of the story uh President Obama was very
much a Star Trek fan a hardcore Star
Trek fan he watched the force awakens in
office but he was very much more upfront
about his fandom for Star Wars uh John
Star Trek you mean uh I'm sorry Star
Trek yeah Star Trek very much a Star
Trek fan he he also enjoyed Star Wars
but was very upfront about being a Star
Trek fan uh uh people on Twitter have
pointed out John you said that people
die in Star Wars and don't come back
they kind of do uh Obi-Wan Kenobi came
back came back but they don't get
rebirthed into life they're just they're
just more transparents than they were
before uh yes good point good point and
uh Andy this is a good judge ship
because there's a lot of confusion uh on
Twitter is where the the TV fights
points beend and the movie fights points
begin in this argument it's very
difficult it's very tricky subject and a
lot of people uh don't really know where
to side I have the fan pole up right now
and I'll let you know how that looks
after you make your judgment look I
think we're we're counting it all got to
count it all uh it's it's one fandom
versus the other fandom and here's where
I'm stuck I think mans had a killer
opening mans had a really really killer
opening that Roa you I had to be honest
you were scraping to catch up with
because he just gave me a much broader
reason as to why Star Trek's more
important but then Roa you really got a
lot of punches and just because the
movies and the and the they don't people
don't die all the things you gave me
have a lot of weight to it
um but it's not about just the movies
it's about the passion and I think you
know to say Star Trek isn't about us
because they want to achieve something
greater I mean Star Trek genuinely does
that is sort of the whole Spirit of it
and you I'm glad you didn't repeat
yourself but you know you did remind me
that I I have to take that opening well
uh but the ads of friendship the things
you did add I still got that that
opening was too strong for me to sort of
ignore I think those were some very
strong points early on I think a lot of
fevered fans are probably mad at me
because you made some very strong points
about the movies uh but between the
diversity and the ins inspiration and
the coming up first and why we all
aspire to be and and United together
like those are things we need and I
think you know are really important and
they're all they're both great they both
have some shitty movies they both have
some good movies uh but I got to give
man that point based on the
arguments harof is going to kill meof is
going to kill me
if I lose a Star Trek argument I am done
Dan thoughts anybody over there uh I I
will say Twitter voted 7822 for Star
Wars over Star Trek assume that so there
you go uh Twitter I think tend to be
trending that way as well but the mostly
everyone agreed that it was a very
spirited discussion yes very good
discussion all right well we're all
winning this one's going to be tough as
well uh huge loss this past weekend with
the loss of Bill Paxton uh so many
wonderful performances he gave and
wonderful films uh and such a nice guy
uh ni guy so such a such a bummer um so
we do want to honor him here and and
just talk about his career uh so this
came in from several people but alpat
Tross was a tweet we got we want to know
what is the best Bill Paxton performance
this isn't trick question with the best
Bill Paxton movie let's focus on the
performance what was Bill Paxton's best
performance roko you're up first all
right for me I there were a number of
things you could choose you could go
aliens you could go Weird Science chat's
fantastic you could go Tombstone even
but I chose a film that not a lot of
people maybe have seen but it is one of
his most critically lauded performances
and that is in a simple plan uh Bill
Paxton with his brother Billy Bob
Thorton in the movie uh they find $4.4
million and they have to and then they
they think they're going to split it
these you know they're kind of like
they're they're all Hamond eggar they're
trying to make it in the world and
they're going to try to say you know
kind of hide this money from everyone
and split among themselves when they get
to it but unfortunately greed
unfortunately suspicion unfortunately as
it happens you know because this is what
happens when people get suddenly come
into a lot of money this stuff it tends
to corrode relationships that are there
and I think what Bill Paxton does here
is deliver one of the most incredibly
nuanced and subtle performances that
we've ever seen from him because we used
to seeing him play these kind of Larger
than Life characters these grandio
characters and then disappear into
characters like he does in Morgan her
and Tombstone like he does in Apollo 13
he's barely even there these things that
that what's great about what he does in
a simple plan is that he lets you into
the vulnerability of this character in a
way that we've never seen Bill Paxton do
and he's so believable in every scene
and the stuff with Bridget Fonda he is
like he is you see the wheels turning
but it's it's a way that's believable
and understandable and you can get it
and you feel for him through the out the
entire movie cuz he's really a good man
trying to do right but these other
elements are coming in and you see these
nuanced situations when these things
start to happen to him in these
relationships how he starts to change
how he starts how you you can see a good
man go back and the reasons why that is
incredibly difficult to do in a small
film this film had a lot of trouble with
production pre-production it went
through three different directors
including Ben Stiller and John do a
number of people were involved in this
production Nick Cage was orig going to
play the Bill Paxton part so you have
this had been working and for 10 years
they've been trying to write this film
and get this film done and when it's
done it's so so good and Bill Paxton
once again shows us something we've
never seen before in any of these other
films yes he's played this kind of
character before but not to the levels
and complex levels that he plays in a
simple plan and by the end you are
heartbroken for what happens to him and
those relationships in that film and it
takes an incredible actor to deliver
that kind of a layered Nuance
performance that carries you through
that kind of film and makes you and
outshines Billy Bob Thorton which is
very very difficult to do at that time
in his career it it's a great film that
you guys should see if you haven't seen
yeah it is a great film uh go ahead man
okay uh this was a tough category and I
was actually surprised he didn't go with
uh with aliens uh you know uh but she's
one of many he's an ensemble there you
know what most of his strongest
performances are supporting performances
that Simple Plan was a lead I went with
Apollo 13 he played astronaut Fred Hayes
and everybody knows the story of Apollo
13 it was it was NASA's most successful
failure because uh two after two
missions to the Moon APO 11 12 landed on
the moon AP 13 which was uh like like
launched at uh 113 and it was all these
like crazy coincidences for bad luck but
so astrona Fred Hayes he was the one who
got sick along the ride and the great
thing about his performance in that film
is it was it was an ensemble movie it
was n nominated for Best Picture lost to
uh Braveheart it lost to Braveheart
based on a true story I think it's one
of Ron Howard's finest films but the
beauty of Bill Paxton's performance in
this movie is that he knows when they
give and he knows when to take he's sort
of the comic relief in the film uh sort
of you know when he throws up uh in the
Command Module um so so he's not comic
relief but things get very serious when
he gets sick and when he does get sick
and the Command Module gets or the lunar
module when they go to the lunar module
the uh Aquarius uh like he like he
looked so his performance was so
convincing that I started I I got called
just watching his performance you know
um but uh I just feel like his
performance uh you know was really a
crucial part of The Ensemble and the and
that meant make the whole greater than
the sum of its parts all right f it out
yeah Mye my counter to you is that a
number of other performances stand out
and and he like you said he's comic
relief in the film that's what he's done
in a number of films he is comic relief
where I think in simple plan we saw
something completely different from him
that we hadn't seen before and it really
broke conventions and I think it
launched him into the second phase of
his career where he's playing these
other characters that are a lot more
solid a lot more stayed so to speak and
and a lot more levels and nuances it
really established him as he
transitioned just like hosner is doing
now into these characters that are the
kind of Side characters but they give
you Foundation like you see in Edge of
Tomorrow like you see him in other films
when he does that he's really great at
doing that and simple plan is the one
that really opened everyone's eyes that
this guy was not just comic relief he
was not just conventional supporting
character he can carry a film or when
you put him in now as an older actor he
knows how to play these complex uh
complex situations Nuance situations he
brings levels to the performance that
people might not have given him a chance
to if they hadn't seen him in Simple
Plan and I think he's he's he's good in
Apollo 13 absolutely no complaints I
just think if if Kevin Bacon is
outshining you Tom Han is outshining you
even Gary sise who isn't even up in
space outshines you and Ed Harris
outshines you then you're you're doing a
good job but you're not there's nothing
you're doing that's going to make you
stand out from the film and I think
that's what undercuts his performance in
Apollo 13 versus what he does in Simple
Plan he's out acting Billy Bob thoron
he's bringing Bridget Fonda to another
level as an actor he's making her step
up to a degree and that's I think that's
that's the power of a of a good actor
okay again you're comparing a lead
performance which is something he didn't
really get to do a lot until he did got
big love where he was like I mean but I
think he wouldn't have got it without
simple plan but but I agree with that
but the fact that he was part of this
Ensemble he was a great supporting
character everyone in that film had
their moments of shine it was it was
again I I mean you know I mean I'm not
going to take anything away from
Braveheart but uh Apollo 13 was also
just as deserving to win best picture
because everyone everyone was on fire in
that movie especially Bill pton he was
not overshadowed by anybody he didn't
get lost you know the the fact that he
did know when to give he gave and he
went big and then you know he he pulled
back when you know bacon had his little
freak out in the Command Module or in
the winter module and you know Tom Hanks
is uh uh you know the the C the captain
uh uh Jim Lovel yeah uh so and it's
based on a true story and it's such an
inspiring film and the way these guys
like were up in you know between the
Earth and the moon and they had to like
use what they had to uh to make it all
the way back it's like incredible it is
it is incredible they are absolutely
lucky that they made it and because of
that I feel like the the true aspect of
it is so inspiring that that actually
elevates his performance well closing
thoughts okay uh like I said with him in
a simple plan it is something we hadn't
seen before from him and I think that's
what makes his performance so much more
amazing we didn't know he could do this
we saw him as chat we saw we even saw
him in in apoll 13 he's yes he's comic
relief his Ensemble gives and takes sure
because he's done that already he's done
that a few times in multiple films
including going back all the way back to
Weird Science all the going back to near
dark or after dark he does he is great
at playing Ensemble stuff what I think
makes his performance A Simple Plan
Stand Out is a lead the hand him the
lead he's going toe-to-toe with Billy
Bob thoron who at that time is one of
the Premier actors working in
independent cinema and he holds his own
and gives even more to that performance
than he gave in in in Apollo 13 and he
carries us through the film without him
the film falls apart without his
performance the film does not work you
could put another good decent actor just
like Bill Paxton into Apollo 13 and the
film would have worked just fine the
film doesn't work without Bill Paxton's
performance and and carrying Billy bobor
carrying Bridget Fonda there is
something about that and displaying what
happens to a good man as he
progressively gives in to the fear and
suspicion and has to question the love
for his brother I mean the love for his
brother he doesn't have to do any of
that in Apollo 13 he he is he's Guided
by Jim level and finds his spot and he
knows he's got other layers of people
that can take care of the situation
before he does again you're comparing a
Lee performance to supporting
performance so so it's what's the best
build backs in performance that's what
I'm arguing lead or lead or or otherwise
okay well well as far as whether despite
the amount of screen time that he had I
still felt like Apollo 13 he is playing
a real life character is a huge
responsibility there and and I don't
think that that role would have been the
same with anybody I mean that's a matter
of opinion but I don't think that role
that movie would have been the same with
it with someone else playing Fred Hayes
I feel like he was he was great in the
role and and it was a great Ensemble
everybody fed off each other and it was
a it was you know he he he he stole his
scenes enough without without making it
all without making the rest of the movie
about him and it could be because it was
about it was about the moment it was a
true Ensemble the people back on Earth
the people up in space all working
together to to fix this
failure all right Dan a lot of people
online uh sharing their own favorites
Eric Monroe say near dark Evan coin
aliens Jonathan PC says True Lies a lot
support including from mpol for Frailty
oh that's a good one that I see a lot of
and that I might and that I kind of I
don't know if it's as best but M did I
love it is this performance in twister
yeah because that is the stupidest movie
in the world and he makes he M he makes
that movie work because
he didn't treat it like it was a dumb
movie everyone in that movie Philip
seamour Hoffman's in that movie and
Helen Hunt like the reason that movie
even kind of works is because nobody
treats it like it's stupid even though
it is patently ridiculous but he's great
in it he's so Earnest in that I don't
know it's maybe not his best but it
might be my favorite of his uh Paxton
also uh won uh was part of the cast for
Apollo 13 they won the SAG Award for
Best cast performance at the second
annual Screen Actors Guild Awards back
in 1996 that's right all right well uh
thought we'd give you a break that time
out of respect to Bill Paxton and we
didn't scream at each other so thank you
C in the storm good luck uh but yeah
great fights great performances in both
so many performances he gave um I gotta
say though it not doesn't matter leader
supporting you know it's about the
performance and I think uh man you got a
little stuck it is Ensemble I think Roa
gave me a better examples as to why he
was more nuanced vulnerable Etc uh his
turn against his brother uh all great
things so I got to give Roa that point
wow so you're up by two up by two look
this a special long episode there's two
more rounds coming two more rounds here
we go question number five Lo what
actress currently 30 or under will be
the next Merill
stre we back here we go SC who is the
next Marl stre just a grade so that way
you know they can only have done so many
movies because they have to be under 30
uh 30 under what actress currently now
do you think will be the next Marl
Street for years to come and uh man is
up first man is first hot ladies and
gentlemen screen junkies movie fights
fans around the world hot on her Oscar
win for La La Land the next Merl street
is without question the one the only the
beautiful Emma Stone Emma Stone look at
her she is gorgeous she displayed so
much range just in this film La La Land
she had to sing she had to dance she at
sometimes at the same time she had to do
drama she had to do comedy she had to
capture the Euphoria of being in love
and she had to show vulnerability and
breakdown almost with defeat when she
almost gave up that was a lot of range
just for one film but wait there's more
she is also an Oscar nominee for giving
a revelatory performance as theung out
daughter in Birdman she worked with
Woody Allen not once but twice working
with Alejandro Ina Ru she gave a an
amazing uh breakout performance in uh
super bad but it was her breakthrough
performance in EA a teen comedy a high
school set comedy that was elevated that
was elevated in one of the best high
school comedies because of her fully
realized performance I knew who Emma
Stone was when I saw Zombie Land and and
obviously super bad but I fell in love
with her professionally I mean while
watching easy I thought she knocked it
out of the park I mean you know playing
a zombie killer of course you know I
mean playing Gwen Stacy in the two
Amazing Spider-Man films and what El
made what elevated those movies were the
chemistry that she had with Andrew
Garfield all right let's hear what John
picked all right my choice uh is last
year's best actress uh winner and that
is the lovely The Talented one of the
stars of Kong Skull Island Brie Larson
who I absolutely love as an actress and
the question is who is the next Merill
stre have we looked over Merill Streep's
filmography you're talking Sophie's
Choice you're talking Kramer versus
Kramer you're talking these very strong
powerful films cry in the dark going
forward into all these other films that
have come out over the last 30 to 40
years that's an impressive career it's
an incredible career so you want a woman
who conveys weight and power and
emotional complexity and this is Bri
Larson this is what she does in room
more so than anything that Emma does
other that one M about her aunt in la la
land and Brie Larson is amazing because
she does has done has crossed multiple
genres of film she's done comedy in 21
Jump Street Scott Pilgrim versus the
world and then the independent films
were spectacular now she's sung on
numerous soundtracks Merill sings as
well she's politically active in defense
of victims of sexual assault Merill is
very political as well and when she won
her Oscar she beat Jennifer Lawrence
sorcy Ronin Kate Blanchett and Charlotte
rampling she didn't need Viola Davis to
not be nominated to win her Oscar she
won it legitimately and she's a great
combination y that you talk is a great
combination she has a great combination
of approachability and talent which is
exactly what Merl stre has she's shown
on multiple uh multiple films how
powerful she is as an actress how
complex how layered how nuanced she is
and when she comes to work and the
chemistry she has with everyone she
works with if you see room that film
with Jake those scenes with Jacob treml
are one of the most powerful scenes
you'll ever see and it's very
reminiscent of early Merill Streep in
that ability like she does in Kramer
versus Kramer when she has those scenes
with her child in Kramer versus Kramer
is very reminiscent the connection the
emotional complexity Emma is a good
actress no argument no argument to well
we'll see great but she's good actress
right EA fantastic in EA it's a teen
comedy she does these other things great
but what Bri does is Bri comes for the
harder stuff she does the independent
movies Emma doesn't do that Nuance kind
of stuff in independent films she does
good work she just doesn't do the Nuance
kind of stuff that you see the power the
weight you know there are actresses and
then there are actresses right and
that's the difference I think Brie
Larsson deserves to be in the
conversation with Merill stre Viola
Davis those kind of powerful actress
Emma Stone deserves in the conversation
to be with Marissa to these kind of
actresses that are powerful when they
they have their moments of power but
they're not their entire career is not
power and I think what Bri does once
again multiple genres of film she
crosses over Kong Skull Island even
train wreck playing Amy Schumer's sister
and train wreck she's great playing Amy
Schumer's sister and train wreck has
incredible nice soft moments with her
child and with Amy's nuttiness all of
that is there with her and all of that
is like just at the tip of her a tip of
her tongue and the tip of her hand she's
so talented can I counter yes C please
okay so you talk about weight complexity
talk about giving layered Nuance
performances uh Emma Stone did that too
in what in uh Birdman and in the help in
bird in the help in the help come on now
in The Help the I'll give you Birdman
wait no no wait I'm not going to give
you help hang on hang on the help is is
a heavy-handed film but her performance
wait a minute hang on you talk not for
those girls it isn't it's handed for the
ma it's not for the Pampered white
that's what I mean it is it is a layered
Nuance performance talk about she wait
she doesn't do Indies what do you call
Magic I didn't say she didn't do Indies
I didn't say I said she doesn't bring
the same weight to them that Bri does no
you said she doesn't do Indies I didn't
say that said she doesn't do I
saiding regardless she did two Indies
she did both of them with Woody Allen
she did Magic in the Moonlight and uh
Woody Allen is independent movies now
get the [__] out of here what El not
independent movies they are that's like
Lucas funded his own film therefore it's
an independent Star Wars film what's
wrong with you there is no way that
Woody Allen films are independent films
no they're Studio funded therefore
inherently not independent film Sony
Pictures Classics Amazon they are they
they're they are own piur classic is
that Sony but film you're talking about
his movies fil movies cost less than $2
million to make it's a freaking
independent film yes it is no it isn't
and listen you also have to look at the
future here look at the okay so let's
look at what do B Lar doing next K Skull
Island Avengers Affinity Wars Captain
Marvel let's talk about what wait a
minute I just said I agreed with you
let's talk about what Emma Stone is
doing next she's going to play carella
DeVille that's going to be a stretch
she's going to be in battle of the wait
wait a minute she's going to be in an
independent film an independent film
called Battle of the Sexes playing Billy
Jean King that movie if I if I had the
guest is going to make the round the
film festivals in the in the fall Venice
Toronto and tell you ride and she is
looking at another Oscar
nomination the very next time and she
will get the Oscar nomination her next
one sooner than Brie Larson will that's
my feeling you're out of your mind if
you think that's going to happen I mean
Bri L Bri lson is isn't another
independent film coming out freefire
which is already that 70s kind of
independent film that is being lauded
all over the place independent film
festivals right now she is working on
numerous projects running now Captain
Marvel like you said if you Marvel picks
the right actors to play those parts not
because their throwaway it's because
they they pick these actors that can
bring complexity and weight because they
explore the emotional uh trauma of being
a superhero in all their films from
Robert dowy Jr to Chris Hemsworth to
Chris and you're not going to
argue can I superhero can I say that's a
cliche what do you mean that's a cliche
everybody does it she's playing Killa
DeVille get the [__] out of same goddamn
thing it's a Disney character been
played four separate times what is so
what is so incredible about
to Captain Marvel right because Captain
Marvel is going to take more effort and
more time has been done multiple times
Captain Marvel's never been
done Marvel chose her to be the first
female Le superhero film in their in
their brand why because she's a
fantastic actress who's going to bring
the complexity of Carol dver to the
screen if you don't know Carol dver
story you got to explore that because
there's she's not just like hey I have
superpowers Way Carol dver has a lot of
stuff going on in her personal life when
she becomes captain and she actually
dies in the history of the comic books
so that you need that's why you need an
actress that has that kind of power that
gets the audiences in the I don't do
that to you don't do that to me I don't
go I don't go come on hurry the [__] up
I don't do that to you I'm just saying
you both do a lot kind of things that
she does right The Glass Castle is
another thing that she might get
nominated for and Basmati Blues which
she's got coming up which has got a lot
of publicity behind it so she has this
kind of power plus she's politically
active plus she can sing plus she's
powerful leading the way she didn't hug
Casey Affleck no that wasn't singing she
didn't hug Casey Affleck she didn't kiss
him because she knows he's he's done
sexual assaults so both the golden and
thear do her the next stre Marl stre is
every you cannot separate Marl Streep's
activism from her acting Merl stre is
Merl Streep and that's what you're
asking me who's the next Merl Streep and
to me Brie Larson covers all the bases
of Merl Streep she will lead the way she
does not do the same kind of character
in every film all right let me tell you
you're both now even cuz I was he was
beating you on Awards but just beat him
on activism and last little thought this
closing will matter when you're talking
about who was the next M stre generally
I mean certainly I I thought we were
talking about acting we're not talking
about personal life we're not talking
about
activism the question is what actress
will be the next Merl Street okay well
when I think of Merl stre I think of
acting and when I think of great
actresses who will be the next Merl stre
top of my list and not just because she
just won the Oscar for La La Land is
Emma Stone she has taken more chances in
the past she's Tak more chances in the
future and who's to say that she won't
get nominated for Cruella she is also
she's also a singer she played she
played bows on uh Cabaret on Broadway
that was the role that got her La Land
she got eviscerated by the critics by
her singing voice they said Michelle
Williams who played it did it better I
have the notices I'm telling you they
eviscerated her voice on on stage that's
why she left the production the way she
did she was she's a good act look if
Emma Stone I nothing against Emma Stone
I don't think she's watching okay okay
okay if anyone knows her I love Emma
Stone to [__] p I think she's a
fantastic actress however I think you're
talking Merl stre Merill stre I think
emone belongs in the Marissa to category
good actresses that step up on depending
on the part with Bri she is always good
she is always nuanced she always has
another level going on she has an un she
has an unspoken level going on with all
her all her performances and there is
nothing that Emma did in la la land that
will come close to what Brie Larson did
in R absolutely disagree absolutely
disagree she despite more range in one
movie and yeah I mean listen I've been
over the top of La Land because I really
love the film but I love her performance
in the movie because it is so layed
because there is so much range to this
one movie but there is wait okay you
don't want me to hurry you up don't
interrupt meor all right you sh shot me
down I'm shooting you down now let me
[__] finish thank you okay she gave
more range in that film I know I already
said this but I'm going to say it again
because it's the truth she gave more
range range in one film than Brie Larson
had in a bunch wait it's in a bunch I'm
not saying her whole career in a bunch
Emma Stone she on top of the fact that
she had to sing a dance and do drama and
comedy and break down and be in love
like people fell in love with her
watching this movie I mean I fell in
love with her again watching this movie
she had me it was just one film and I'm
looking ahead to the Future she is
Taking Chances she's taking chances she
could go the easy route and play a
superhero movie she already did that she
had her the Disney route that's not easy
at all oh but car DeVille she could get
nominated for that she could get
nominated for playing Billy Jean King in
battle of sexas and I'll bet you she
does I bet she doesn't I'll bet you she
does bet she do I'll bet you $5 says she
get nominated are we betting $5 here's
my I'll bet $100 that she do you're on
$100 I'm okay so we're saying $100 that
emone will get nominated for Billy King
you're saying say I I don't think I
think the film's going to crash and burn
uh here's disagree here's of course you
disagree $1 technical team behind La
Land FYI oh great the one that just lost
best picture uh so let's let's take a
look at this what you just said are
supposed to be the closing but yes so
you're 10 seconds okay okay Brie Larson
Brie Larson in playing a villain in
Scott Pilgrim versus the world fantastic
don't tell me that she doesn't don't
tell me that Emma Stone that's
ridiculous we just said right she does K
Skull Island because you're saying that
Brie Larson's performances in all these
other fil Skull Island did you see it I
haven't seen it no okay I did okay I did
and it's okay yeah you're just saying
that to any argument though you're just
saying that to any AR is she good in the
film she's fine talk about mean like
Emma Stone and numerous other films just
fine anyone could have played the role
she is anyone could have played her in
super bad what's the difference
underwritten role it's an under anyone
could have played her in super bad that
was such an easy role to
play it was Michael Sarah and Jonah Hill
who stood out it was not people went who
M was more known gave a lot I'm going to
give you that was it you got a Lot
quickly you get 10 seconds you well I
mean I I I mean I again I've said
everything at the top I mean she she's
done better work in the past she's taken
more chances in the future she she's
looking again I mean you know we don't
know yet but she's looking at another
nomination I believe
it Dan crowd over there what do you guys
think well
uh I would like to point out that you
know John uh brought John brought up the
the concept of uh uh Emma Stone didn't
need you know that Brie Larson beat so
and so so and so and so the Oscar to be
fair Emma Stone beat Merill Streep so
you know I wouldn't have opened that
door if I were you Jenkins though that's
like just saying that was not a secondly
a good R John uh said that Woody Allen
does not make Independent films he was
nominated for an independent Spirit
award for Blue Jasmine Vicki Christino
bar Barcelona Bullets Over Broadway okay
by their rules the independent Spirit
award rules it is a movie with a budget
ceiling of $20
million um so a
lot but a lot some of his movie his last
movie for example Cafe society would not
have counted under those rules a lot of
his previous movies would have counted
so he has a foot firmly in both does
that include an hle and that was a
studio that was that was a was a
different time was a very different time
picture and uh lot of people pitching a
Tatiana masani who they believe masani
if they gave her more movies
absolutely what's the show uh
black tevion a lot of people
saying all right oh and the Twitter poll
is very close it's changing by the
minute so wow
wow based on the arguments uh I love you
too
man a little got a little hot there got
a little hot for a second it's happen
yeah hey you guys take this seriously
that's why I love you both uh it's
really tough actually but when you went
back and compared the roles and then
when Scott did uh uh reveal sort of the
Skull Island which I don't even know if
he's supposed to do uh performances and
things which we'll keep on the download
because it doesn't go on YouTube
Saturday shush if you watched early um
uh it it all came back to like I think
Scott gave me a little bit more of an
argument as to how she's on track to
become more of the Merl Street where
while Bri Larson will be great doesn't
necessarily mean she's going down that
same route So based on the arguments I
got to give it to a man very close
though when when Stone when Bri is on
her fourth Oscar I just love Emma I know
and Emma's great I love you know what I
believe it's hard to fight against but
it's
honestly I
love poll is currently
5149 Emma Stone
wowow right now all right all right we
got we're we're way we're 90 minutes we
still have a fight cuz we added one but
we got to do this because the Oscars
just happened we just touched upon this
we just touched upon this the fans
demanded this I think I know what you
guys are going to pick we're picking two
movies Scott you're going to fight La La
Land yes sir John you're going to fight
Moonlight also known as a masterpiece
best film of the year we're going to
argue this fight all right let's do this
uh wait who goes first wait JT you have
something up
there oh trick question what what oh so
John that means you'll be arguing that
La La Land is the best film of the year
what what Scott you'll be arguing that
Moonlight is the best F I can't do that
I can't do that what I can't do that hey
you guys are the best you had to throw a
trick at you oh man wait wait a minute
wait wait wait you you actually want me
to argue
against I can't
[__] wait no that's hey either one of
you wants this thing I had to argue for
Jurassic world on this show so nut up
and argue
guys up yo JT you're
[__] dude wait trick question my
friend is in Moonlight Andre Andre
Holland who plays thef to you it's [__]
now
Dan it's a fellow seminal Dan oh my God
this trick question is worse than that
that that that [__] show that happened
at the end of the Academy Awards I
thought I was moving only fitting I
wanted to watch for all say why La is
the
best M give me m okay we go all right
here we go so to clarify you must argue
in the opposite film so Scott you are
arguing against La La Land Moonlight is
the best film La La Land is [__] and
John you must argue for La La Land and
Moonlight is [__] this will prove who
really earns this point who deserves to
be here this is about debate about
arguments Roa you're up first why is
Moonlight a far superior film to La La
Land La La Land a far superior film
sorry why is La La Land a far superior
film to wait wait wait hang on hang on I
don't I cannot believe I cannot believe
this I don't believe you can't believe
this I can't believe at the same level
you can't believe it trust me trust me
oh my God I was ready to
eviscerate
see is an amazing amazing fil yes it is
it should careful I got to clarify If
you defend the other film you like okay
yeah strike that from
the it last pass go you're hna uh La
laed is one of the most amazing films
that has come out in the last 30 to 40
years it Embraces the musical genre
which is so difficult to to do and many
people had declared that genre dead and
La La Land brought it back to life it
brought it back to life with two
incredibly charismatic and Powerful
actors in Ryan Gosling and Emma Stone
their chemistry their connection with
each other throughout the film you buy
it you feel their pain look spoiler
alert cuz we're going to argue these
films you feel their pain when the
romance ends you feel their pain when
she comes to visit him at the end in the
jazz club and he looks at her and they
have this amazing American and Paris
inspired uh uh sequence where go and see
what their life could have been like if
they had ended up together and it's so
powerful I cried so much in that moment
you know but that's real that's real
stuff La La Land explores this this
human emotion yes people have criticized
oh it's too pretty people [__]
that's La that's actors there's a lot of
pretty people who suffer and never make
it you know they end up in porn or God
knows where and that's just how it
happens sometimes you know so what La La
Land does though is it awakens your joy
of Dreams having a dream fighting for it
who hasn't been that level of Barista
working close to the studio wanting to
break through wanting to be seen wanting
to be heard how many of us have a Silent
Scream Of Our Lives and that comes
through in la la land it comes through
so powerfully in la la land yes yes you
have uh uh uh Ryan Gosling explaining
Jazz white splaining or some people
criticize it wh splaining Jazz white
people like jazz too white people can
understand Buddy Rich Jean Kupa Jet
Baker there are plenty of white people
Jean Scott there are plenty of white
people who have done Jazz and have
killed it in jazz and have loved jazz
and so you can't use that argument he
really explores when he's having that
when he's explaining Jazz to Emma Stone
he's explaining Jazz to the audience
itself and that is such a wellone scene
and then we'll get more okay Scott why
is Moonlight a far superior film to La
La
Land I hate you this counts this counts
against his time by the way okay that is
hard here's why
Moonlight everyone knows you're doing a
trick question okay here's why Moonlight
is a superior film Moonlight changed the
game Moonlight was a daring film
Moonlight was a brave bold Beautiful
film it is a masterpiece it is it is uh
uh spans it spans three different time
periods its Boyhood meets Brokeback
Mountain by way of boys in the hood that
may sound like a crazy pitch but that's
what that movie is the power of that
film
a Coming of Age story about sexual
identity in in the African-American
community at a time when when both
movies about a feature for both sides
are few and far between here's a movie
that has done with Grace with beauty the
performances across the board are
absolutely brilliant the the the Chara
each of the actors playing the the the
boy growing up you have Maha Ali as this
as this drug dealer who who unwittingly
takes it upon himself to be a father
figure to this young boy who needs a
father figure in his life he won an
Oscar for it he won a lot of awards for
it all of them welld deserved Naomi
Harris filming the role of the mother in
just three days because she was in the
middle of doing the Press tour for the
last Bond movie Spectre and that she
still is the only character in each of
the three
timelines and she is the thread of the
movie and she got nominated for it welld
deserved and and she's an amazing
actress but the last scene of the film
in the diner is is so genuine it is
organic it is deeply deeply moving that
these two guys that had one moment that
touched them for the rest of their lives
one moment and that will carry them
through the rest of their lives and the
movie ended on such a beautiful
beautiful notes and that is why the
movie deserved to win best picture all
right now you guys both defended your
films great but I need you to hear you
guys criticize while the other films are
[__] I'm about to jump into that all
right so the Moonlight the problem with
moonlight is the narrative and the story
structure yes Mahar Charlie comes in
he's great right at the beginning and
then he just disappears nothing there's
no wrap-up to the storyline Naomi Harris
she's terrible mother she there's no
progression in her character to where
she's sitting and has the apology at the
wherever at the reception the the
whatever Drug Center she's at Treatment
Center she has to sit there but there's
no like progression she's just like I'm
sorry for being a bad mom sorry all
right cool let's move on there's no
waight to those moments because they're
not earned Mahar disappears and at no
point does shyon mention him again at no
point does he talk about him again this
is one of the most influential people in
his life I feel that's that's a
detriment to the film and then when he
gets into when he has the situation when
he sees the sees he goes and drives
drives down and meets up with the his
friend who was the gun who gave the gave
him the hand job on on the beach All
That Jazz like you goes down there yes
it's unspoken but it's unspoken in a way
that it's like you have to do all the
work as the audience and there needs to
be some kind of end to that situation
some kind of conversation about that
situation all they talk about is INS all
they talk is ins stilted and then he has
that moment he leans in on him what does
that mean okay great we had a hand you
gave me a hand job we found each other
again and we're back in the same
position we were sitting on the beach
listening to the water but there's no
progression he is a gang member now the
other dude's a chef right he went to
this but why why we don't we don't know
why we don't know what happens we're
told everything instead of instead of
seeing the experience of him becoming
these things and I think that's the
problem with the film that undercuts the
power of the film the film should have
been more devastating than it was and it
copped out on its ending and it copped
out on its narrative structure in
certain moments and that's where
Moonlight where La La Land doesn't do
that La La Land shows the progression of
that relationship the end of that
relationship in in uh [__] montage
and when it happens you feel the end
because you feel for both both of them
wanting to connect and being unable to
connect and circumstances keep them from
connecting and then when they move on
you see them move on we are shown them
moving on and exploring their lives him
opening the Jazz Club her becoming uh
using that one woman show and he drives
out to bring her back to Hollywood so
powerful you don't just get a blank uh
black screen chapter 3 and then she's a
successful actress you get it all as you
watch through La La Land moonlight just
handers you La Land suck oh
man
okay
I this has been my most favorite fight
ever in the history of this show got
care about the point I don't really know
this is the experience of this St make
it stop this is like asking you're about
to conceed the point here's why la la
land
sucks okay's watching by the way
watching you have this movie about
shallow self-absorbed people oh man who
are how dare you so full of themselves
they're pursuing their
dreams I'm sorry Scott Hear do this so
full of their dreams they forget to
connect on a romantic level they do it
for a little while but ultimately they
care more about their shallow of
self-absorbed careers because they want
to be famous than working it out to stay
together you talk about a movie that
cops out at the end what do you call the
end of La La Land oh let's what would
have happened when the reality is they
didn't love each other enough to stay
together boy that's really inspiring I'm
going to watch a movie that makes me not
believe in love because these two s
absorbed kids can't work it the [__] out
wow I would disagree with you completely
what are you talking about Scott every
one of us has that one great love of Our
Lives that just didn't work out because
of timing and factors and what have you
and we have that that moment where we
see them again years later and we have
maybe over coffee or maybe on the drive
home you rem you think about what your
life could have been with that person
and it's really moving and that's how
you grow and mature and as an adult
that's why Ryan is a different person
when he's at when he's at the piano
playing that riff when he comes out of
that riff and that whole sequence he's a
different person because he's had that
experience Emma is a different person
and they at the end when she's about to
walk out the door they have that moment
where he he gives her the smirk the Ryan
Gosling smirk and she gives him the
smile and that's smile is the understand
thanks for being there at one of the
most important parts of times of my life
thanks for coming driving out there and
making me come back you changed my life
thank you for inspiring me to start this
jazz club because if you had been in my
life I might not have been motivated to
do these kinds of things and that's
where La La Land is really it's power
Scott
thoughts you went there keep going hurry
up talk about a movie you know you're
talking about oh what happened to Mahar
Ali he he never you never see him again
they mention that he died but they don't
have top on it they just move on it's
it's years later he had enough of an
impact on the kid he had enough of an
impact on the kid and and when we're
when we're moving forward through time
you see that this this moment that they
had together on the beach in the
Moonlight it it wasn't just a hand job
as you describe it it was a moment of
love it was a moment of sexual Awakening
it was a moment that they never forgot
and as grown-ups as adults they living
different lives one's a a gangster the
other one's a a chef at a diner but they
they love each other the love for the
two of those men in Moonlight felt more
real and genuine to me than the shallow
self-absorbed love between Ryan Gosling
and Emma Stone who could not they could
not stay together love con wait a minute
hang on love conquers all love conquered
all in Moonlight it did not Conquer All
In in la la land absolutely it did
because Ryan loved Jazz more than he
loved anybody else and he opened that
club but so he's in love with that I my
Emma found her screw you but Emma found
her husband and they have two beautiful
kids she's happy with him she did find
love love J sometimes love no she didn't
settled she did not that guy walked into
that place and walked her through it and
was to care
ofy from that thing you do she settles
you change as you grow and you different
people fit you better at different times
of your life she followed her head she
didn't F her heart and neither did she
followed her heart and her head because
she wanted to be a successful actress
that that's what gave her life to that
was
ambition he dies but we don't see what
his we don't see what his effect is on
Chiron at all and it was yes it was more
than just a hand job but he never let
another man touch him he never let
another man touch him and the other the
chef moved on and had kids with another
woman and a wife and all this kind of
Ja it's a convenient drawn back together
it only happens because him if he was
that driven he would have found him but
in fact he waits for the chef to call
him and then he goes oh yeah maybe I
should go figure this out maybe I should
get the down by the be out there was
there was not as much years later they
went out of their way to find each other
who who went out of their way that the
chef called the guy he just found the
number he didn't go out of way it was a
friend of his with the number to you
just said it went out of the way they
still found he drove down they said they
found each other and the moment that
they had together was strong enough but
but that they that they were
back but love doesn't conquer all
they're damaged they're broken from that
hand job they're not in love with each
other at the end they're broken one's a
gangster and one's a chef in prison for
10 years it doesn't matter in prison for
10 years what matters is that they came
back together the law was strong wait
their love wait listen to me your point
says love cers up but it doesn't the
love was strong enough to triumph over
the adversity that each one whereas
whereas these two white people God
couldn't work it out they couldn't work
it out out because they were so driven
by wanting to be an I mean listen she
she she she wanted to be an actress she
wanted to be famous she wanted to be a
star he wanted to open his own jazz club
they could have worked it out they
didn't they the moment when in la la
land when they had the argument after he
comes home the surprise dinner like the
whole movie like like so so that that
one argument means they're not even
going to try to work it out that wasn't
enough I wasn't convinced well if you I
cannot believe I'm saying if you go if
you are in a relationship you know there
is that one moment that one argument
that just happens that fractures the
relationship and there's no going back
and that's what that argument was and
that's they don't they didn't have like
four hours to explore the whole they
gave you enough through the montages to
understand that there was love but they
were but they were also kind of like
missing The Mark with each other a
little bit and they both were kind of in
each other's way why was that a good
thing that is a good thing because
that's reality sometimes the wrong
sometimes the right person comes at the
wrong time and you you explore that
relationship and the relationship
doesn't work and you move on and you
progress but you're supposed to learn
from that relationship it's supposed to
make you stronger they both they both
lifted each other up in that
relationship and the ending of that
relationship is what allowed them to
flourish and Thrive pursuing the things
that they love her acting and him Jazz
so their love did conquer all she's
happy with her husband he's happy with
his jazz club and they still have that
understanding and connection at the end
when she just before she walks out like
I mentioned that moment that moment is
the most one of the most powerful
moments we've seen on screen all in all
of
2016 more so than than closing go ahead
I I say you know you say that people
come to each other's lives to at the
right time well that's what happened to
these two guys when use my argument get
your own argument well you're you're
supporting my argument more than your
supporting my because you know I can I
can speak from experience and say that
yes there is a big argument that could
happen that could derail everything but
if you love each other you work it the
[__] out that is that is reality and in
Moonlight in Moonlight these two guys
your wife was not the only relationship
you've ever had a minute no she's not
well but in other relationships we've
had arguments we work it out it doesn't
work out for other reasons but the one
that I'm in now certainly did right of
course and and everyone loves your and
everyone loves your wife and I'm happy
that you're happy with any other
clothing aside from you well yes you
know you talk about about about reality
the reality of the situation is that
this movie moonlight it it took tab a
taboo subject and it made it accessible
and it was told in a beautiful organic
deeply moving heartbreaking way and true
love whether it happens at just a moment
that it stays with two people for that
long whether they had a moment they were
reconnected many years later that moment
depicted true love more than most movies
where they stay together from from start
to finish
right that was fun D for you maybe I
have no
factchecking I think you're a sist for
letting that go on as long as it did but
that's beside the point hey do you want
can we have a hug Scot you want a hug I
got to have a hug I got I got have Aug
sorry I'm sorry
L wow you guys brought it oh my God I
think the fans loved it though right Dan
uh the fans felt bad for both
participants oh God it was one of the
hardest things I've ever had in I cannot
that be like me saying that Star Wars is
better than Star Trek oh anything else
to add we almost had them fight whether
Star Wars was better than star Tre we
almost we thought about it we were going
to switch that one but uh we thought
your passion on that one was going to be
more intense so glad we kept it Jesus
Christ all right based on the arguments
who who was right I hate you I I got to
say I think I got to give it to man what
uh his turn there for me even I was to
lose it based on your points but you're
and then you got personal with it the
the you really hit it hard on where
those things didn't work and I thought
you G back to why moonlights uh were
stronger um I got yeah man you get the
point [__] did he really did they say he
died I don't remember them saying they
said they said one quick moment funeral
they said funeral
funeral it spoiler alert sorry well I
mean damn it
I didn't even know when I saw the movie
so I just won wait let me get completely
wait guys I just want to just process
this for a minute I disagree completely
we could you said we were supposed to
bring our own personal stuff he just won
of moonlight I won saying la la land
sucks yes oh my God oh my God all right
worth it what a show I love it we're
going spray the speed round here we go
what how does this work again oh come on
I don't remember you don't remember
let's do it let's do
it uh okay weird choices here why didn't
we take some of the rejects from the
other things do we have any of those
available Max should just give me the
point should have checked these sorry
just give me this point that would have
been the end of it yeah uh
okay oh okay all right uh all right
we'll try some of
these I can't stand so weird I can't
stand number two is so
weird okay guess I'll try it uh here we
go number
one you guys know how this works I don't
need to explain it to you use a home you
you'll catch on we're good right I think
so yeah best movie featuring Jason
steam
crank I heard crank first from man crank
no uh you said crank you said crank I
said crank yes uh [__] what's the guy
Richie one I forget what the guy Richie
one was can someone help me sh ah sh
change mine no [__] can I change mine
uhow God damn it spy Spy fine [__] why
can't I remember that goddamn name okay
were you looking for uh snatch snatch
that's what I tried to say you got spy
Crank versus spy man you go first okay
crank is a balls to the wall it go it is
it is an adrenaline fueled crazy wild
ass movie it is off the rails and it
shows Jason Stan kicking butt but really
just going for it it is over the top in
all the best ways and it really just
shows how committed Jason Stam is when
he wants to really really kick ass uh
there's nothing we haven't seen him do
before that he's he doesn't crank in spy
he's doing comedy he's doing fun he's
doing he's making fun of this character
that he's built up over all these
separate films he's fantastically funny
he's got great chemistry with Melissa
McCarthy and he does his stunts he gots
he gets all his action in and he throws
in comedy so he shows he shows a
multifaceted performance multi-layer
performance in spy and now people look
at him as a possible comedy lead okay
you know what crank he also shows a lot
of comedy in that movie movie too you
have to laugh at this movie but crank is
a Jason Stan movie he's in every
freaking scene of the movie Spy he's a
supporting role it's really Melissa
carthy's movie it is not a if you you
just argued like lead versus supporting
what's the difference what I think what
I think here in STM is that he does such
fantastic work in in knowing the Nuance
is a comedy something we hadn't seen
before cranks Over the Top This is more
nuanced you get two seconds cuz he he
went long uh crank crank is it's a it's
a it's a it's an action film that's what
stat is okay let's make sure I even that
that okay guys on the couch I need your
help based on the arguments where are
you guys
sitting I think I'm going
towards mans just because I thought Roa
got a little hung up on the last
question where he was arguing the the
inverse of sure his argument Simone i is
her mic on is it okay hi I would have
said John I think uh just the
multifaceted aspect of that performance
and it's more surprising anybody else
want to chime in yeah what do you guys
think I probably say man just cuz it's
uh Jason's movie kind of in the lead
role versus him supporting Melissa
McCarthy
Dan I don't know if it's fair for me to
chime in considering that just uh I
would uh I think I'd lean roa's way on
this one I felt like uh man I was
arguing me a little bit more on Jason
Statham I think Roa was was selling me a
little bit more in the movie so I'd lean
toward Roa that's where I was leaning
too oh so Roa gets the first point there
in the speed round how many we have five
yes okay you're up by
one here we go this is a weird
one if Godzilla ever speaks in a movie
who should provide the voice V
diesel James Earl
Jones all right let's hear
why first vend diesel who's already done
the voice of iron giant he's already
done the voice of Groot so already he's
he's had an abil amazing ability to
create these voices for these characters
and endear you to your heart people love
Godzilla people always love Godzilla
both in Japan and across the world and
so to have Vin dies will do a new voice
for this amazing character would blow
everybody's socks
off okay okay if you're going to have
somebody talk and use a voice have to
say full sentences and not just broken
ones like he did in the other films
James Earl Jones is Darth Vader and he
he like everyone knows the voice and
nobody can project that ominous deep
dark commanding sense of dread and power
like James Earl Jones that's exactly
what we said everybody knows the voice
is Darth Vader so people will get
confused they won't focus on him whereas
vindis has shown he can do different
type of characters with his voices and
people like both all those characters as
well James again he just said a couple
words in each of those films he didn't
actually say full sentences and James
old Jones yeah he's most famous for
Darth Vader but no one's going to
confuse Godzilla with Darth Vader all
right I'm going to give you an extra 3
seconds to give me your impression of
what the line would
be die
Mothra okay Scott citizens of
Tokyo you have met your
match all right that did help me guys
over there God damn it I'm a voiceover
artist God damn it
I mean based on the voice I I gotta go
with Scott SC that wasn't even close to
James R Jones anybody else yeah all
right looks like I see nodding heads all
right Rance gets the point damn it damn
it yeah that was a slam
du until the impression yeah is the
impression matter it sure does damn
it have done a better job okay what is
the best year in movies 1939 1994
1939 versus oh wait I'm sorry 1939 all
right no it's fine it's okay 1939 versus
what 1994
okay so Manser first okay you got Gone
With the Wind you have you have the
Wizard of Oz you have you have uh uh uh
uh uh the uh James James Stewart and
uh uh uh the uh watch Mr Smith Goes to
Washington those three movies all right
you got three in go ahead you P fiction
you have Forest Gump you have shash
Shank Redemption this is one of the most
powerful uh uh changing C course
Corrections in cinema history in 1994
It's a combination of independent field
with the popular mainstream culture
that's what you have in Shashank that's
what you have in P fiction and that's
what you have in Forest Gump it works
all around three all right you know
what's going to help me here is list as
many give me some more to wait here in
your last 10 seconds cuz I only got
three for can we use our phones
nope [__] this is fair because we did
ask you in advance this was an alternate
question yeah Scott time starts and You
Begin speaking I'm I'm just going to say
that those three movies alone were done
at a time when the world was falling
apart was about to Ender World War II it
was already going on in the rest of the
world America was almost there and you
have these three movies especially going
with the Wind and The Wizard of a as
which changed the game well what you had
in 1994 was you had these this
independent in influence and you had
something Shak a lot coming out you had
all these kinds of films that coming out
in 1994 as well these Independent films
that were really burning up the screen
and changing the course of Cinema can
you check Chuck I just trying to that
was
not4 was I love that you gave them the
criteria to win the round and neither of
them chose I got I don't know 39 but I
know Lion King speed professional
there's there's a lot of 94 sorry my bad
say 99 but it's all right uh Good Year
as well all right uh yeah based on those
I got to give it to Scott I think those
are the I don't know anyone else can
lean me that way that's where I'm
leaning I went I would I went toward Roa
I felt like he answered the question
better before he got nudged than Scott
did but it's yeah I they both had the
avenue to win and neither of them took
it I don't know I I was looking toward
Roa based on uh what based on the I
thought that he uh number one showed a
little bit more knowledge of his year
number two I thought that said shock a
lot well he did that's that's the UN
took me out of it the lot thing that's
why I'm having trouble I was still lean
toward Roa but I I just I think that he
argued more for the the course
correction even though he got the one
wrong I don't know that's just me yeah I
gotta go like if you just hadn't said
choc a lot I would have given it to you
I got to give man I mean wizard of VZ
going at the wind I think are pretty
hard ones to beat if you would just
given me quantity which I think you
could have done uh you might have got it
I I'm going mans all right 54 wow all
right here we go so that's we've done
three right jeez it's like pen statec
this is uh this the third one must win
for John Ro must win okay I want to make
sure we give you a good one
[__] uh sorry just making sure we go
through these
all wow John yeah I'm telling you buddy
what a match so weird what a match all
right to all the LA Landers out there I
love you worst movie where Matt Damon
plays the lead the great Jason
B Jason Bourne versus the Great
Wall okay so who said which go first you
say Great Wall Great Wall okay go ahead
greaty wall is one of the worst films
I've ever seen in my entire life it is
it is it is white exploitation of
another culture again it has his
fantastic elements you saw that was
terrible in 47 R then he steps in and
they they make the entire movie all
about him he's a white guy going to to
China to defend the Great Wall so it's
such an insult to that culture such an
insult to that Cinema and an insult to
that mythology of that history
you know to have Matt Damon reprise the
world famous role the role that that his
Action Hero role of Jason borne in a
film that was that shouldn't have been
made it felt dated there was nothing to
it it it was a travesty to the character
that he would play it again in a movie
that just was such an absolute
disappointment I did not expect the
Great Wall to be good I expected Jason
Bourne to be great and it was awful
Jason Bourne was a decent film it's a
decent entry into the franchise they're
not all going to be great ones but great
wall is a terrible you look Rotten
Tomato score I bet it's way worse so the
question is what's the worst Matt Damon
lead film and the answer is the Great
Wall Jason boring you know the the the
the first three movies they got better
progressively better as they went along
after Ultimatum It should have got
better and it was like the worst it was
like The Phantom Menace of Jason bour
movies that should never have been
made all right little tougher for me uh
Dan when all else is equal I go with who
argued the movie and mans argued the
movie to me and I have to go with mans
on the couch raise your hand for rope
oh wow all of them all right oh I didn't
see all right I couldn't see over there
uh so it's Dan and the versus the crowd
picked Mance I mean picked Roa
uh yeah I to
me I I think you did pick the worst film
uh John you made a really good argument
though you were expecting more at a born
but you did say it's an okay film it's
not the best in the franchise so I'm
leaning towards BR on that point so I'm
going to give it to them with with the
fan couch all right so we're tied this
is this is it always going down to the
last question I'm so tired of I'm going
off book is this the last one yes yeah
off book on this one oh man this is one
we asked them on the phone and it's
fitting oh [__] name a movie that
features the best rivalry SP Theon uh
empire ST
back here we are well well we meet on
the field of battle again young man so
Wrath of KH versus uh Wrath of KH versus
what did you pick uh empire ST back okay
we're really going doubling down okay
ratha Khan I mean you got Kirk and Khan
it is one of the greatest rivalries in
movie history you have the great hero
and you have the villain both of them
are chewing their scenery yet they are
never actually on screen in the same
scene at the same time that is the power
of the Rivalry is that people don't
actually realize that Shatner and what C
Mound chw their scenery so much fully
realized characters based on literature
now you have Luke Skywalker versus Darth
V this is against his father and against
convention his father wins the evil wins
at the end that is not that's and it
includes one of the most powerful
Moments One of the most iconic moments
ever when he tells him Luke I am your
father and the Rivalry continues over
three films it isn't one and done it's a
rivalry that continues and in this film
it is never more powerful because Vader
wins and we think Luke what's going to
happen to Luke we don't know okay I
don't 10 seconds use them wisely guys I
don't see Empire stength back as a
rivalry I mean it's it's it's a
fatherson thing but it's not really a
rival Kirk and Khan are Rivals you know
Khan is is embittered because he
banished his crew his his his wife but
in in a rivalry means the other team
wins every once in a while Khan has
always lost to Kirk whereas Vader and
Vader and Luke is always changing back I
give my 10 seconds they argue back and
forth and finally Luke wins in in the
end and in fact they come back together
all right I'm going to give him 15 final
seconds okay Dan Scott don't interrupt
each other don't talk about it just let
them have their time 15 final seconds
use them wisely go okay first of all
Khan did win against the Enterprise on
that first battle and it was because
Kirk knew more about the ship that he
saved his crew and he even even was
taunting Khan talk about Rivals Rivals
should taunt each other remember that
line Khan I'm laughing at your Superior
intellect that's what Rivals do every
time he every time Kirk wins Khan every
time every time Khan tries to win Kirk
always beats him and beats him every
single time whereas with this this is R
where Vader wins Luke wins Vader wins
Luke wins and then finally at the end
like all good rivalries they hug it out
at the end and and they come together
just like we do and that happens at the
end of Jedi when they come together and
he saves his father's
life so here's where I stand I think
repeat back to me the question yeah name
one movie that has features the best
rivalry and I think Roa got a little
lost in the trilogy whereas Mance got
stuck with uh with one film and told me
why so I just I'm curious does anyone
have any disagreeing thoughts on
that I'm a huge fan of rivalries that's
why I want to sit in on this one um
but I thought Mance killed it when he
was saying that KH and uh they're more
of rivalry there but then Roa totally
brought it back with it they have to
even they they have to sometimes win and
sometimes lose for it to be a good
rivalry so KH never lost that or KH
never won tilted me in the slightest
towards roken interesting all right so
you're saying by we're not getting lost
in the trilogy he's just pointing out
that that's why two was so sign
significant yeah he's saying that that
you can't have a rivalry if one person
always wins Fair uh guys in the back any
thoughts I need help on this this is all
for all the marbles I saw a question
it's you're talking about one movie yeah
I said one movie features the best
rivalry one movie okay go ahead yeah I
agree I don't think that mentioning the
rest of the trilogy is a bad thing it
just puts more weight under it I I would
go with with John which is I said the
whole I didn't mention Spacey you all
you all agree so all the fans are are
would vote for Roa Dan I I think that uh
I I I I'm with your first instinct I
think that Manz was talking about the
Wrath of Khan he's talking about the
Rivalry between Kirk and Khan in The
Wrath of Khan and I think that JN was
more spread across I think that if
you're arguing The Wrath of Khan versus
The Empire Strikes Back the argument for
The Wrath of Khan was Stronger well I
just want to say I argued that Vader won
in that and then I use the trilogy to
support why that was important I heard
you I I I I did hear that that's why I'm
having a discussion because I want to
make sure I do this right in the booth
JT I'm going to the booth based on the
arguments this is like more Beady at the
end of the Oscars um I got to give the
edge to Scott only because I agree he
really closed in on the one movie and I
don't fully agree with what he said
where rival have to make up at the end I
don't think that's
[Music]
true all right I want to make sure I
didn't end on Dan get some other
thoughts cuz Dan does have a bias
against
you I wanted to hear it all all right
turn you can turn the mic off in the
booth all right based on the
arguments uh man this is tough I'm
really I'm really stuck in the middle
but I got to say it is based on the film
I did Clearly say pick a film and I do
think Manz gave me a more of an example
of what why that rivalry was better in
that
film I'm sorry John I got to give it to
Scott D yes very close I hope you'll
respect that choice yes it really came
down the argument that I was uh laa land
forever lava land forever start Tre CE
the day LIF long and prosperous screen
these fans man well there we go that was
a very long show what time is it I don't
even know my phone dies 3:00 in the
morning oh yeah I I don't even know if
we can get to after the fight at this
point I think you got an extra long
episode instead uh so let's go through
and thank everybody uh as our after show
here on the show Scott man's
congratulations wow come on John give it
up really came down the wire wow
anything you'd like to plug yes I would
like to plug this guy John Roa he is an
amazing guy he's a great human being he
is full of passion he is smart he is a
Survivor he is a fighter and it is my
honor and privilege to whoop your ass I
love
but come on Round of Applause for
[Applause]
Mr man you are you proven though you got
I'm bringing you back more because this
is uh soon cuz you you brought it today
congrat that was I think your best fight
too well I think going back and forth
with our conversations and stuff like
I've I've been honing my game you know
and so I'm learning as I go along and so
I I I it sucks to lose I hate to lose
especially being up 31 uh and I you know
you can make arguments whatever so but I
always appreciate coming on I love it
it's sucks it hurts afterwards to lose
but I still enjoy fighting it and I'm
still learning every single time and so
at some at some point I'll be ready for
you at some point but I'm getting back
I'm getting I'll be get ready I'm okay
with one and six it doesn't mean my
season's over my moment praise
thisy oh I learned and I'm getting
better at this I I get a little bit of
time
Scott and of course Scott thank you very
much for the kind words it's always a
bless to go Toe totoe with you you're
one of my favorite people on the planet
and you always have been you already
said that so shut up stop cutting me off
stop cutting me off but yeah this is a
blast and to do in front of an audience
was is a little bit intimidating so that
was a blast to a good a good extra level
to play with brother thanks for having
me on no thank you both uh let's go to
the audience Jake uh and Bri thanks for
coming guys any final thoughts hey I
would just like to say as a again as a
fan of rivalries I love watching Roa
mans Roa Merl
JT Patriots and Trek on Theo Andy
fighting Christian whether it's here or
there so I hate seeing people give a
bunch of crap to these guys cuz they
have a lot of schedule conflicts and
stuff like be happy that these guys do
all this stuff cuz it's really fun to
watch so thank you man we try and fit it
in we'll be I'm excited to fight we're
doing some fights against them soon so
stay tuned uh in the back we have uh
Matthew and Antonio uh anything you'd
like to to shout out uh we just want to
say thank you for having us we uh we
just got married on Friday
yeah oh
wow celebrating with us I love it and
it's it's so far the best honeymoon ever
so all right I love it thank you guys
for coming congrats that's beautiful
Simone right yeah hi I can't stop that
but yeah uh I just have one thing to say
it's
v as a French Canadian I have to say
yeah any great that's very helpful thank
you for that anything you'd like to plug
no yeah I don't know I'm on YouTube but
it's in French so ah check it out is it
called lay YouTube or is it still
YouTube you man well yes we'll have to
check it out and thank you all for
coming Dan Merl on the couch what a show
huh that's the dumbest question I've
ever asked in my
life no uh so much fun uh so it's a
great to see these guys fight Roa thank
you for holding on to my property for a
while shut your mouth I'll be back to
get it soon come get it come get it get
it son no subjective nature there come
get it man man has earned the first seat
in the
semifinal facing a one-onone there you
go man you're in it wow congratulations
you are in there next week we'll be back
with Paul shear and Kamal I can't K Nani
thank you I'm terrible with names uh but
that's and we have a and a mystery third
guest uh DVD but uh it's gonna be very
fun that show is going to be awesome
Star wattage so tune in they're both
legit movie fans so it's going to be a
lot of fun and thank you for watching
you can follow me at Andy signor and all
the Instagram Twitter things and uh keep
us me present we're going to be putting
more on my Facebook Facebook and stuff
to get your questions on the show more
often because we want to get some new uh
thoughts here so thank you for watching
stay tuned for more March Mania couldn't
do this without you we love you guys
bye-bye
bye every podcast we put on YouTube
comes with this Kick-Ass graphic listing
all the topics your favorite screen
junkies podcasters are talking about if
you click the topics you can skip around
and choose your own podcast Battle
Royale go ahead try them all if you
haven't already subscribe to screen
junkies on YouTube to join us for future
fights or if you prefer to listen on
iTunes click the logo to download an
audio
[Music]
version